Und dabei herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio 247 live aus dem Chaos Computer Club Berlin in der Marienstraße 11 in Berlin. Und falls ihr das gerade an einem neuartigen Rundfunk-Umpfangsgerät hört und denkt, vielleicht könnte ich da auch hingehen. Das könnt ihr tatsächlich, könnt ihr da vorbeikommen. Wir haben noch ein bisschen Platz. Dann könnt ihr zuhören, wie wir heute über Computerspiele reden. Und ich finde das eigentlich erstaunlich, weil in meiner Erinnerung ist es dafür, dass das Chaos Radio, der so ein Radio mit Digitalkrams ist, noch bis jetzt, ich glaube, gar nicht passiert. Oder zumindest relativ selten und es wurde auch mal Zeit. Und ich begrüße deswegen recht herzlich Johannes Christmann, Jörg Friedrich und Stefan Höfelbrink. Hallo und guten Abend. Sehr schön, Sie sind alle da. Das kann man nicht nur hören, auch sehen, unter streaming.media.ccc.de. Da winken wir gerade in die Kamera, wuhuuu, und die Idee, diese Sendung heute mit diesen ganz bestimmten Leuten zu machen, kam ein bisschen daher, dass es etwas gibt. Und ich zieh das jetzt so ein bisschen aus der Tasche, diesen Vergleich. Also wir senden ja aus dem Chaos Computer Club Berlin, es ist ja ein Hacker Space und es gibt den Saftladen in Berlin, das nennt sich Gaming Collective, aber immer wenn ich mal da gewesen bin, dachte ich so, das ist schon auch so ein bisschen ähnlich. Also da sitzen Leute an Tischen und machen was mit Code, aber das Ergebnis ist halt ganz, ganz, ganz anders. Und dieser Vergleich muss jetzt sozusagen diese zwei Stunden tragen, die wir hier miteinander verbringen. Und das soll heute ein Einblick werden ins Computerspiele machen, nicht im Sinne einer Einführungsveranstaltung oder eines Leitfadens, sondern eher so, wie es das Chaos Radio manchmal macht, so anekdotisch. Also man erzählt ja ein bisschen, wer sind die Leute, was machen die, wie sind die dazu gekommen und das ist ja vielleicht auch sozusagen mal ein Fenster in diese Welt hinein. Mehr als nur zu spielen, sondern auch eben das Spiel zu machen. Aber bevor wir über all das reden, ist ja zumindest eine Sache, also ich werde jetzt den Vergleich zwischen Hacker und Gamemacher noch ein bisschen bemühen. Eine Sache ist ja auch so, die man immer nachsagt, hier sitzen jetzt wieder vier Dudes mit Bärten und sprechen über Technik. Gibt es keine Spielemacherinnen?
Doch, die gibt es schon, aber nicht so viele.
Okay, warum? Weiß man das?
Naja, das ist so ein bisschen diese Katze, die sich selber in den Schwanz beißt.
Es gibt nicht so viele, deswegen sind auch nicht so viele motiviert da hinzugehen?
Genau, auch das und warum ist halt so ein bisschen Historie, wie Spiele beworben wurden, so ab einem gewissen Zeitraum, dass dann halt immer mehr so ein Spielzeug, Jungs, genau, einfacher zu machen, eine Zielgruppe zu erreichen, dadurch, okay, wir konzentrieren uns auf die jungen Männer und dadurch waren Frauen ausgeschlossen, haben wir trotzdem konsumiert, aber halt, ja, es ist so ein langer Ratten-Schwanz an Problemen, den wir da versuchen aufzurollen und wir kommen voran, aber es ist schon noch ein Haufen Arbeit vor uns.
Und es ist auch so, wir haben es für diese Sendung versucht, aber es war, glaube ich, die Treuker aus entweder nicht deutsch sprechend oder nicht im Lande seiend oder gar nicht erst auf die Anfrage antworten, die dann dazu geführt hat, dass es jetzt doch wieder so aussieht wie immer. Unfassbar, aber jetzt zu, ja?
Es ist aber auch ein bisschen besser geworden.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, also wir hatten durchaus Kandidatinnen.
Ja, genau, und ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt schon zu einer, aber Jo und ich haben ja vor langer Zeit mal zusammen studiert und da waren nur Jungs, also wirklich nur Jungs. Und ich unterrichte heute unter anderem da, wo wir studiert haben und da sind zum Teil Kurse mit die Hälfte Frauen. Das ist schon besser geworden.
Zu der ganzen Geschichte, wie ihr zusammen studiert habt und wie man generell sozusagen dahin kommt, dass man das macht, kommen wir später noch. Jetzt wollen wir erstmal klären, wer seid ihr denn überhaupt? Also ich möchte jetzt gerne rein nach von euch wissen, wer ihr persönlich seid und was ihr so macht. Dann in welcher Organisationseinheit oder Kollektivform ihr arbeitet und dann vielleicht das, weil wenn ich die Zeit habe über alle Spiele zu reden, die ihr heute macht, so das Spiel, wo ihr sagt, okay, das ist, wenn ich mich vorstelle, ist das, dieses Spiel ist momentan so ein bisschen meine Visitenkarte. Vielleicht das Beste, was ihr gemacht habt oder das, was ihr gerade seht, das könnt ihr natürlich selber entscheiden. Stefan, du hast noch fast gar nichts gesagt, fangen wir bei dir an. Wer bist du denn eigentlich? Stefan und ich bin ein Solo-Entwickler und ich arbeite eigentlich auch seit drei Jahren nur an demselben Spiel und das ist eigentlich auch mein erstes großes Spiel, also davor habe ich nur ganz viele kleine Sachen gemacht. Aber immer alleine?
Ja, ein paar waren so in Kollaboration mit anderen Leuten entstanden, aber die meisten davon habe ich wirklich alleine gemacht.
Das heißt also du bist ein Spielentwickler und du bist auch deine eigene Firma sozusagen?
Ja, inzwischen eine Firma.
Gerade vor wenigen Tagen gegründet, bis jetzt war alles noch amateurhaft.
Und was ist dieses Spiel, an dem du da arbeitest?
Das Spiel heißt Death Thresh und ist ein post-sopagolitisches Rollenspiel.
Und wenn du das sagst, sagen dann Leute immer, das ist ja sowas wie Fallout. Okay, aber sag doch mal, für die Leute, die nicht wissen, was Fallout ist, was ist ein post-apokalyptisches Rollenspiel und was passiert da?
Oh je. Ja, ein Rollenspiel ist eigentlich so eine Mischung aus verschiedenen Dingen.
Also man steuert ein oder mehrere Charaktere, man erkundet eine Welt, man spricht mit den anderen Charakteren in der Welt, manchmal bekämpft man die auch.
Und man kann meist auch sehr viele andere Dinge da machen, wie sich durch die Gegend schleichen, irgendwelche Schlösser knacken, irgendwelche Hacking vielleicht, sowas noch. Und Fallout ist so ein Prototyp für diese Mix von Rollenspielen mit dieser post-apokalyptischen Welt zusammen. Jetzt ist es aber so, Fallout ist ja so irgendwie 3D-Ego-Perspektive. Nein, das fing ja die ersten Fallouts ja nicht. Na ja, gut, aber wenn man heute mit Menschen spricht, die noch nicht so alt sind, dann bin ich alt. Man muss ja sagen, die Time Lines waren jetzt gerade wieder voll von Trailern zu dem nächsten Fallout-Titel. Das ist schon eher fotorealistische 3D-Grafik. Was ich fragen wollte, ist, der du seit drei Jahren alleine in einem Spiel arbeitest, ist wahrscheinlich anders? Nur eine Vermutung? Also ich verwende Pixel Art, eher so einen dreckigen gemalten Pixel Art-Stil. Der hat jetzt mit Fallout selber nichts zu tun. Ich verwende halt dieselbe Kameraperspektive wie in diesen alten Fallout-Spielen. Schräg von oben.
Dieser gemalte Stil passt da so ganz gut zu. Ich wollte jetzt sagen, der ist natürlich einfacher zu machen als realistische 3D-Grafik, aber im Detail ist es dann doch ein bisschen komplexer manchmal.
Okay, da können wir vielleicht noch im Detail drüber reden. Jörg Friedrich, wer bist du? Wo kommst du denn her?
Hi, ich bin Jörg. Ich bin seit 2003 in Berlin und mache hier Spiele. Und ich habe auch eine Firma, ich bin eine zweizellige Einheit im Saftladen. Wir sind zwei Leute, haben eine Firma, die heißt Paint Bucket Games. Und unser Erstlingswerk ist ein Spiel, bei dem man eine Widerstandsgruppe spielt im Dritten Reich hier in Berlin. Man managt die und man macht Missionen mit denen. Man versucht im Prinzip zu überleben. Und das Ende dieser Zeit zu erreichen. Das Spiel heißt Through the Darkest of Times.
Was heißt man managet die?
Man ist eine Figur in dieser Gruppe. Man ist nicht ein Charakter. Aber man ist der Anführer. Die Story dahinter ist, dass man die Gruppe anführt. Man schickt die hauptsächlich auf Missionen, um mehr Unterstützer zu bekommen, um das Regime zu schwächen und Leuten zu helfen. Diese Gruppe, ich nenne es Strategie-Adventure, besteht aus verschiedenen Charakteren. Die haben tatsächlich einen Hintergrund. Die haben verschiedene politische Ansichten. Manche sind verheiratet, manche sind Juden, manche sind homosexuell. All das spielt mit rein in dem, was der Gruppe macht.
Wenn du sagst Management und Mischung, werden diese Action-Sequenzen gespielt? Ich entscheide, wer mit auf eine Mission kommt. Dann wird automatisch ausgewürfelt, was da passiert.
Es ist eher Letzteres. Ich entscheide, wer mit auf eine Mission geht. Ich bekomme dann kleine Geschichten. Kleine Textabschnitte, in denen ich entscheiden kann. Dann kommen die vielleicht wieder zurück, dann passiert was. Dann wird jemand verhaftet, dann wird vielleicht ich verhaftet, ich werde verhört. Ich muss Antworten geben, dann kann ich mich entscheiden, verrate ich jemanden oder nicht. So läuft das ab.
Ein Widerstandsmanagementspiel einer zweiköpfigen Firma. Wenn Stefan gesagt hat, er macht das alleine, dann muss ich nicht fragen, was er macht, weil er macht einfach alles. Was machst du?
Ich mache alles außer Grafik. Das heißt, ich mache, ich programmiere, ich schreibe viel, ich mache das Game Design. Ich denke mir die Spielsysteme aus, sowas alles. Die Grafik macht der Sebastian, der heute hier nicht ist, genau.
Ist das eine klassische Aufteilung oder gibt es klassische Aufteilung, dass man sagt, also bei kleinen Teams ist es oft so, einer programmiert und der andere macht die Grafik oder ist das sozusagen ganz verschieden?
Ich glaube, das ist ganz verschieden. Oder wie ist das bei euch so?
Also ich würde schon sagen, dass traditionell wahrscheinlich der Split ist zwischen Grafik und Programmieren. Es gibt schon auch so Twitter-Wesen, die dann beides bedienen, also Stefan oder auch in größeren Teams. Aber ich glaube, wenn ich jetzt überlegen würde, dass einer codet und der andere macht irgendwie Sound oder so, ist eher ungewöhnlich.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber jetzt so Game Design zum Beispiel, das ist ja oft auf beide verteilt. Oder das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt, also da ist irgendwie egal, wem das dran hängt, ob das der Techniker macht oder der Grafiker.
Dem tun so wenige so gut wie du mit Sebastian, der sich da raushält.
Aber das ist, also man kann schon mal sagen, also der Split irgendwie einer prog mit einer macht Grafik, der ist, der kann eher häufiger auftreten und den Rest macht man so zusammen. Also irgendwie das Spiel, Design, die Mechaniken irgendwie zusammen vielleicht ausfallen. Üblicherweise schon. Genau, ok, Johannes, erzähl doch mal, wie ist das denn bei euch?
Ach so, ja. Hallo, ich bin Johannes. Ich bin genau wie Jörg auch seit 2003 hier in Berlin, komme aus dem Süden. Ich habe eine Firma gegründet, nachdem ich lange im Mainstream-Bereich Spiele gemacht habe, unter anderem Speck of the Line gearbeitet, habe ich 2004 eine Firma gegründet, die heißt Maschinenmensch, zusammen mit Ria Jemili. Und da machen wir auch hauptsächlich Spiele, zum Beispiel The Curious Expedition, das ist bisher unser einziges richtig veröffentlichtes und kommerzielles Spiel. Das geht um Expeditionen im 19. Jahrhundert in unterforschte Territorien der Welt, so im Stil von Jules Verne oder von Humboldt, die Expeditionen in Südamerika. Allerdings kommen dann auch so fantastische Elemente dazu, wie so Dinosaurier oder Riesenkrabben, die einen dann furchtbar auffressen. Den Kopf abschneiden mit der Schere.
Kein gutes Spiel ohne Riesenkrabben.
Kannibalisieren sich dann, also richtig fun und feel-good-game. Ist aber auch so wie Stefan in so einer reduzierten Pixelart-Optik gehalten. Und viel mit Text auch. Also es ist ein sehr reduziertes Spiel, eben auch da, durch das wir es zu zweit gemacht haben, also Riad und ich, ganz bewusst ein kleines Spiel gemacht, weil wir halt eben aus dieser großen Produktion kamen, wo man so mit 120 Leuten zusammengearbeitet hatte und gesehen haben, oh mein Gott, da muss man auch so viel verkaufen. Deswegen wollten wir lieber ein kleineres Spiel machen. Das war dann eben die Expedition. Das haben wir dann auch jetzt mehr oder weniger fertig. Man kann ja nicht die Finger davon lassen und macht immer noch so ein bisschen weiter. Aber jetzt haben wir jemanden eingestellt, der das weitermachen muss. Und wir machen es nicht mehr selber.
Okay, ihr seid damit fertig?
Nein, immer noch nicht. Ich habe gerade vorhin, bevor ich losgefahren bin, ich bin fast zu spät gekommen, weil ich noch mal dran was gemacht habe. Also ich kann auch nicht die Finger davon lassen. Aber wir machen auch noch ein paar andere Sachen. Zum Beispiel habe ich auch den Saftladen mitgegründet. Und wir sind auch so ein bisschen im kulturellen Umfeld, rund um Spiele tätig mit Maschinenmensch.
Okay, es ist bei den Sachen, die ihr über Spiele machen erzählt habt, sind mir dann zwei Dinge aufgefallen. Das eine ist, ich spekuliere jetzt darauf, Through the Darkest of Times ist wahrscheinlich auch Pixelgrafik.
Nein, es ist 2D auch, aber es ist nicht Pixelgrafik. Das ist so ein bisschen handgezeichnet, das Stil. Es geht so in Richtung Schernschnitt so ein bisschen. Es orientiert sich, ganz grob, es orientiert sich eigentlich an Kunst der 20er Jahre. Wir haben einen Stil gesucht, den die Nazis verboten hätten. Es geht so ein bisschen in Richtung Kette Kollwitz.
Aber auch sozusagen ein... wie soll man das sagen?
Stilisiert.
Stilisiert, genau so abstrahierstilisiert. Das ist jetzt bei allen drei Spielen so. Jetzt ist ja Pixelgrafik auch hip gewesen, vielleicht in den letzten Jahren oder immer noch da. Ist das auch eine Budgetfrage? Ich meine, ihr seid jetzt alle kleine Teams und ihr macht alle reduzierte Grafik, nenne ich das jetzt mal, der Einfachheit halber. Ist das nur eine ästhetische Entscheidung oder ist das schon auch eine Entscheidung für... da muss man... Wenn ihr jetzt sagt, also irgendwie Stefan hat ja gesagt, seit drei Jahren, Johannes sagt, man kann sowieso nicht die Finger davon lassen. Also wahrscheinlich hat man auch an dem Grafikstil unendlich viel zu tun. Aber ist der einfacher zu managen oder woher kommt das? Also das ist jetzt Zufall, dass hier drei Leute sitzen, wo es sozusagen ähnlich ist.
Also ich komme ja auch aus dem Mainstream-Bereich, habe auch lange in großen Teams gearbeitet und auch lange in Positionen, wo man irgendwie so Kram gemanagt hat und sozusagen ausgerechnet hat, wie viele Leute braucht man, wie viele Grafiker braucht man, um den Wald zu bauen. Und es ist ja einfach immer eine pragmatische Entscheidung mit dabei, denke ich. Also ich denke, es ist sehr schwer, wenn man eine rein kreative Entscheidung trifft und sagt, die erfordert aber ein Budget, das ich nicht habe, dann wird es halt nichts. Also von daher spielt das, glaube ich, immer mit rein. Ich finde das auch eigentlich eine gute Sache, weil man einfach, es gibt dieses geflügelte Wort, ohne Beschränkungen gibt es keine Kreativität. Ich glaube, wenn man Beschränkungen hat, dann kann man innerhalb von denen kreativ sein. Und das ist auch interessant.
Okay, wenn ihr bedächtig mit dem Kopf nickt, ist es im Radio immer total gut, wenn ihr noch so wenigstens zustimmend ist. Ja, super, genau, wenigstens sowas. Stefan, wie ist das bei dir? Du bist ja sozusagen, vielleicht würdest du sagen, du arbeitest da dran. Mit dem Schlimmer könnte ich auch vermuten, du bist da drei Jahren gefangen mit der Entscheidung, die du mal getroffen hast. Ist das sozusagen, ist das was, wo du denkst, ah, hätte ich es doch anders machen sollen? Also ich habe sehr viel gelernt in der Zeit und würde jetzt einige Dinge auch anders machen und könnte die jetzt auch schneller machen, aber die Zeit war ja irgendwie auch notwendig gewesen, um mal diese Schritte so zu lernen und einmal durchgemacht zu haben. Und also zu dem Grafikstil wollte ich noch sagen, bei mir war das auf jeden Fall eine Bewusstseinscheidung, dass wegen der Optik den zu wählen und natürlich weil der auch irgendwie machbar ist, aber machbar wäre vieles, also zum Beispiel auch einfache 3D-Grafiken. Also was man ausschließt sind so diese high-end, hochrealistischen 3D-Grafiken, wo man irgendwie drei, vier Wochen an einem Charaktermodell sitzen würde. Das sitzt natürlich nicht drin, aber daneben gibt es viele andere Stile, die man wählen könnte in der Machbarkeit und die auch ähnliche Vorteile hätten.
Zum Beispiel diese bisschen Stilisierung oder ein bisschen abstrakter, was ja auch ganz gut ist für den Betrachter, dass die Vorstellungskraft noch ein bisschen mehr da eingebracht wird.
Also, ja.
Also ich sage mal, fotorealistisch kann ja eigentlich jeder. Ist ja wirklich nur eine Frage, wie viel Geld du halt auf dein Spiel wirfst. Aber wenn du dir mal so Spiele anguckst, wie jetzt zum Beispiel Stefan's Spiel, da ist halt, also sowas kann nicht jeder. Da kommt dann eine künstlerische Komponente dazu, die außerhalb von rein technologischer Umsetzung oder von einfach einem finanziellen Möglichkeitenrahmen ist. Sondern da musst du eine Seele reinstecken in das Spiel. Und da musst du mehr rein geben als einfach nur, ich werfe da jetzt ganz viele 1000-Euro-Scheine dagegen. Und dann sieht es irgendwann fotorealistisch aus. Das ist ja langweilig, das will doch keiner.
Das ist aber schon auch ein bisschen stolz. Guck, ich kann mit diesen einfachen Mitteln auch dieses geile Ding machen.
Natürlich, man steckt ja auch viel rein. Du bist ja in so einem superkleinen Team. Natürlich steckst du auch extrem viel von dir selber in so ein Spiel rein. Und ich könnte mir nichts langweiligeres vorstellen als an einem fotorealistischen Spiel arbeiten zu müssen.
Glaubt ihr, dass Pixelgrafik, ich schweife ein bisschen ab, aber es muss kurz sein, weit überleben wird? Pixelgrafik wird immer verbunden mit dieser Nostalgik der frühen Computerspielzeit. Die sieht ja mittlerweile auch anders auch, weil jetzt auch Technologien angewendet werden, die es damals gar nicht gibt. Ich kenne die Fachbegriffe nicht, Shader oder Weichzeichner. Ich spiele jetzt gerade ein Rollenspiel, was auch in dieser Japano-Pixelgrafik ist, das aber so ganz viel mit 3D und Tiefenschärfe arbeitet. Die Mittel sind ja schon auch schneller, aber meint ihr, das stirbt trotzdem irgendwann weg?
Also wenn du es mal nicht auf Pixelart reduzierst, weil letzten Endes, egal welches Bild, man hochskaliert. Wenn wir mal über Stilisierung reden, dann finden wir eine gemeinsame Basis. Und ich glaube, Stilisierung wird niemals wegsterben. Ganz im Gegenteil, was wir jetzt gerade erleben, ist sozusagen auch was, was die traditionelle Kunst durchgemacht hat. Immer mehr eine Annäherung an das Realistische. Und irgendwann kam dann der Impressionismus um die Ecke und hat gesagt, wisst ihr was? Ist mir doch scheißegal. Ich mache jetzt mein eigenes Ding hier. Und ihr seid auf einmal alle total langweilig. Und daraus ist dann eine Explosion von neuen Stilarten entstanden. Und da sind wir eigentlich, denke ich auch, wenn wir so was Ähnliches erleben, bei den Spiele machen. Jetzt rennen sie gerade alle sozusagen der realistischen Grafik hinterher. Aber was ist denn, wenn wir das erreicht haben? Was ist denn dann? Dann geht es ja nicht mehr weiter. Dann ist es halt fotorealistisch. Okay, geil, es sieht halt gut aus so. Ein Jahr später sind die Leute gelangweilt. Und dann fangen sie an, halt eben neue Stilrichtungen zu suchen, neue Wege zu suchen, um sich auszudrücken visuell. Und da sind wir ganz klar die Vorreiter.
Jetzt könnte man jetzt noch eine schöne Diskussion hinterher schieben, also wenn ich nicht mehr unterscheiden kann, ob ich in einem Computerspiel bin oder nicht, dass es dann gerade wieder zur Aussage wird, das Computerspiel so zu machen, dass ich genau weiß, dass ich jetzt in einem Spiel bin. Aber ich will noch eine andere Frage stellen, die mir aufgefallen ist bei dem, was ihr erzählt habt, über das Computerspiel machen, nämlich keiner von euch macht Sound. Ist Sound was? Was bei Computerspielen, muss ich als Radiomann natürlich extra fragen, was man eher so hinterher macht. Also man sagt, ich kapiziere mein Spiel mit der geilen Pixelgrafik, die sozusagen selbst Impressionisten blass werden lässt und eine schöne Game-Mechanik. Und dann suche ich mir jemanden, der vertont das mal.
Also Sound wird ganz oft unterschätzt, das stimmt. Und das ist mit Sicherheit nicht... Also zumindest nichts, womit ich anfangen würde. Ich bin, glaube ich, auch... Das ist generell, glaube ich, nicht so audiophil.
Lass mich die Frage mal ganz konkret stellen, Stefan. Machst du zu deinem Spiel auch die Sounds und die Musik selber?
Nee, genau. Da habe ich jemanden, der dann sowohl Sound als auch Musik macht.
Aber generell zu den Audiosachen, die funktionieren halt ganz gut.
Also man kann das Spiel ganz gut ohne Audio erst mal entwickeln, dass es funktioniert, von den Mechaniken hier und dergleichen.
Deswegen ist das, glaube ich, so eine Sache, die oft extern passieren kann und dann abgenommen werden kann. Ja, bei euch? Macht bei euch jemand Sound im Team?
Ja, wir arbeiten mit der Almut-Schwacke, die ist auch im Saftladen. Das ist ein Foley-Artist, das habe ich jetzt erst gelernt, was das ist. Sie hat sich auf Geräusche spezialisiert und unterstützt uns da. Und die kann das einfach viel besser als wir.
Aber sie gehört nicht zum Paintbucket. Sondern sie ist auch eine externe Quelle.
Ja, das ist eine externe Quelle. Wir haben einige externe Quelle. Wir arbeiten auch noch mit Leuten, die uns beim Schreiben unterstützen. Das bleibt, glaube ich, nicht ganz aus bei einem Zwei-Leute-Team. Dass man sich Hilfe holt. Aber ich möchte schon, und das gilt auch für alle Externe, dass die mit in den kreativen Prozess einbezogen sind. Also dass die nicht nur... Dass du sagst, hier ist unser Spiel, jetzt mach mal... Schreib mal eine Geschichte dazu. Oder mach mal Sound dazu. Sondern dass man sich früh hinsetzt und sagt, hier ist das Spiel, das wir vorhaben, das sind die Dinge, die wir planen. Was wäre denn dein Input? Was könnte man denn da noch machen?
Aber das ist ja schon eine Unsekundzulation. Also, ich meine, es gibt ja auch Spiele, die ohne... Na, ohne dass jemand im Team früh dabei wäre, der auch eine Affinität zum Sound hätte, wären die nie entstanden. Also, was weiß ich, Guitar Hero ist ein einfaches Beispiel vielleicht. Oder hier Electroplankton, ein altes DS-Spiel. Spiele, die eigentlich Sound im Kerngameplay auch haben. Oder hier Raze auch. Extrem, würde niemals funktionieren, ohne den Soundtrack, diese Spiele.
Aber das sind ja Spiele, also die Beispiele, die du nennst, für die Leute, die es nicht wissen. Das sind alles sozusagen Spiele, wo man mit dem Sound spielt oder auf dem Sound spielt. Das ist ja aber sozusagen eine sehr kleine Kategorie von Spielen.
Weil es vielleicht nicht so üblich ist, dass die Soundaffinen-Menschen im Core-Team sitzen. Aber gibt es ja auch. Und außerdem machen wir ja auch Sound. Also, Stefan oder wir, wir beauftragen ja sozusagen Menschen, die das besser können als wir. Aber wir haben ja auch eine Meinung dazu.
Entschuldigung, es war wirklich gar nicht als Vorwurf gemeint. Es war wirklich nur das Interesse, an welcher Stelle das im Prozess stattfindet.
Ich finde nur wichtig, dass man eben auch das tut, selbst wenn man es nicht selber macht. Also ich meine, ich sage ja auch meinem Programm, was es für Grafiken generieren soll. Ich mache die ja nicht selber auf den Monitoren, auf die farbigen Pixel.
Aber es ist sozusagen noch eine Abstraktionslehrer dazwischen.
Das stimmt.
Okay, wir hören jetzt mal rein in ein so ein Ding. Das ist jetzt von euch von Curious Expedition, von einem Soundtrack, der Track heißt Elektra. Wer hat den dann gemacht?
Alexander Batsch hat es gemacht. Das ist auch so in unserem Alter. Der hat mit Ria zusammen, war der auf der Schule. Das war ganz lustig. Da haben wir einen ewig langen Ausfallprozess gemacht, mit welchem Sound-Leuten wir zusammenarbeiten. Und haben die alle durch so riesen Reifen springen lassen und lange Ausfallprozesse. Und zum Schluss hat er dann das Rennen gemacht, einfach nur weil er mit Ria in die Schule gegangen ist. Aber es war eine gute Entscheidung, weil der war der verrücktest von allen, der unerfahrenste von allen, was Spiele, Soundtracks und Musik angeht. Aber war das experimentellste und damit auch am besten zum Spiel gepasst. Und wir sind super froh, dass wir das gemacht haben.
Gut, dann hören wir der jetzt mal rein. Und danach sprechen wir ein bisschen was Connections beim Spiele machen, auch für ein Rollenspiel. Elektra war das vom Curious Expedition Soundtrack und das ist eines der Spiele von den Menschen, die heute im Chaosradio zu Gast sind, nämlich Johannes Christmann, Jörg Friedrich und Stefan Höfelbrink. Herzlich willkommen zurück. Und ihr dürft ruhig Hallo sagen. Sonst weiß man gar nicht, dass ihr da seid im Podcast nachher. Ihr seid zwischendurch gegangen. Wir haben jetzt gerade darüber geredet, wer ihr seid und was für eine Art von Spielen ihr gemacht habt und wollen gleich mal drüber reden, weil ich habe am Anfang diesen Vergleich bemüht, Hacker Space, Saftladen, dieses Gaming-Kollektiv. Bevor wir aber darüber reden können, was der Saftladen ist, müssen wir glaube ich drüber reden, wo ihr eigentlich herkommt. Also wie ihr zum Spiele machen gekommen seid, warum und welchen Weg ihr genommen habt, der dann letztendlich in diesem Ding endet, was halt ein Gaming-Kollektiv ist. Naja, das ist der Auffanggrube. Naja, wenn die meinen Hacker Space sagen, dann denken die Leute immer, das sind diese Stock-Phototypen, also so Hoodie vom Computer nicht beschieden.
Genau, so sehen wir auch aus.
Und Saftladen stelle ich mir halt genauso aus. Das ist ein dunkler Raum, alle Fenster sind zugehangen.
Wir sind im Keller.
Alle mit Hoodies.
Alle ganz bleich vor allen Dingen. Genau, Hoodies auch.
Wir werden auch ständig angerufen von Leuten, die ihren Drucker nicht installieren können.
Meist Counterstrike.
Ich hab hier den Netzwerkdrucker, ich krieg den nicht. Nein. Ich hab's einmal, dann konnte ich nicht helfen, und dann haben sie es voll realisiert. Nee, ich bin die falsche Person.
Das passiert ja. Das geht an Menschen, die sozusagen...
Vor allem nicht Verwandtschaft ruft da oft an.
Wenn man über Digitalthemen am Radio redet, wird man auch gefragt, ob der Drucker vielleicht... Von daher hätt es mich jetzt nicht wahr. Aber wo kommt ihr her? Jetzt hab ich schon irgendwie Johannes und Jörg gehängt irgendwie zusammen.
Ja, wir haben sogar mal zusammen gebohnt.
Genau, das klang schon vorher an. Bevor wir dann in die Intimdetails einsteigen... Wir hören erst mal, was Stefan zu erzählen hat. Dann werden wir mal gucken, was wir da vielleicht noch aus euch rauskitzeln. Stefan, bist du als Spielemacher geboren worden? Oder wie ist das passiert? Nee, aber das fing schon recht früh an. Im Jugendzeitalter dann irgendwann, also in den 90ern noch. Das waren noch Zeiten, damals mit Q-Basic und dann mit C, so die ersten Text-Adventures, die waren auch so kreativ benannt wie Dungeon, Dungeon 2, Dungeon 3 und irgendwann was Grafisches, das hieß dann Dungeon Fighter, war auch schon ein Rollenspiel und dann, naja, irgendwann später hat es dann aber wieder aufgehört, bin ich irgendwie ein bisschen von abgekommen und dann habe ich irgendwie so jahrzehntelang irgendwie gar nicht mehr so viel mit Spielen gemacht. Sondern? Ja, alles Mögliche. Ich war eigentlich so jemand, ich wusste nicht genau, was ich überhaupt wollte und dann, ich habe zwei Jahre im Altenheim gearbeitet und ich habe viele Jahre auch mit meinem Vater zusammen in der Firma gearbeitet, in so einer kleinen Druckerei oder Druckvorschufenbetrieb, so nennt es sich das damals noch.
Und bis vor ungefähr fünf, sechs Jahren und dann habe ich irgendwann, aber dann konnte ich einfach nicht mehr.
Also das hatte überhaupt keine Zukunftsperspektive und ich war so frustriert von dem. Inwiefern Zukunftsperspektive? Im Sinne der persönlichen Erfüllung oder des Geldes wegen oder?
Ja, also die Druckbranche ist ja jetzt nicht unbedingt so ein zukunftsweisendes Ding.
Es wird ja eher weniger Papier genutzt in der Zukunft. Also ich kenne da Firmen, aber ja. Ja gut, aber generell, ich meine, allein durch die wahnsinnige Konkurrenz im Internet, war das gerade für so eine kleine Firma auf dem Lande dann auch noch sehr schwierig. Ja, aber jetzt ist ja irgendwie, also alleinstehende Spielentwicklung jetzt nicht unbedingt ein Job, den man wegen des großen Geldes und der Zukunftsperspektive ergreift, könnte ich mir vorstellen. Ja, aber warum soll man in einem Job festhängen, der auch kein Geld bringt und dazu noch Scheiße ist? Dann kann ich ja besser den Job versuchen, den ich immer machen wollte. Also bei mir war wirklich, das hat einfach so, das ist fast übergelaufen. Ich konnte einmal nehmen, ja. Und dann bin ich zusammen mit meiner Frau hier nach Berlin gezogen und hatte dann auch erst überlegt, zur Uni zu gehen und Game Design zu studieren. Da hatte sie so eine Bewerbung abgeschickt. Aber mir war schon irgendwie klar, ich versuche jetzt erst mal so einfach, das selber zu lernen. Also ich war immer so ein Autodidakt.
Und habe dann ganz viele kleine Spiele gemacht.
Ich konnte ja auch eine Weile überleben, noch mit den eigenen Ersparnissen, die ich hatte. Die Reste aus der Druckerei. Also wir kriegen es wie gesagt nicht aus Flüchen, aber wie macht man das, sich selber Spiele machen beizubringen? Ja, also es gibt ja im Internet genug Material, also es gibt ja alles mögliche im Internet zu finden. Ja, aber das ist ja auch das Problem. Kannst du vielleicht eine Quelle nennen, wo du sagst, das war total hilfreich, was ich mir da angeguckt habe? Also ich bin irgendwann auf die Entwicklungsumgebung Unity gestoßen. Und die macht er dann um einiges einfacher für mich. Ich mag die Programmiersprache, C-Sharp, die man da verwenden kann. Für so ein Ein-Mann-Team ist das so eine gute Mischung aus, dass man viel machen kann, aber es auch gut zu machen.
Und ja, aber wirklich YouTube-Videos, alles Mögliche.
Also ich weiß, dass ich damals Programmieren gelernt habe, hauptsächlich durch irgendwelchen anderen Quellcode angucken und dann die eigenen Sachen da reinhecken. Also ich wusste, da gab es damals irgendwie so ein DirectX-Demo, so ein 2D-Grafikzeug, da gab es eine Quelldatei. Und da dachte ich, okay, damit kann man irgendwelche Spots auf dem Bildschirm machen. Dann häcke ich jetzt meine eigenen Funktionen da rein.
Also für eins dieser ersten Spiele.
Und das war dann so eine einzige Quelldatei gewesen, wo ich mein komplettes Spiel dann geschrieben habe. Einfach weil ich es nicht besser wusste.
Aber so fängt man halt an.
Oder ich fing somit an. Und jetzt hast du gesagt, du hast vor sechs Jahren am Schluss ein Spiel zu machen. Seit drei Jahren sitzt du an, wie heißt es, Death Trash? Death Trash, was hast du in den ersten drei Jahren gemacht?
Sehr viele kleine Spiele.
Und die dann auch verkauft? Also wovon lebt man als Einmannenspieleentwickler? Ich hab da keine Einnahmen gehabt.
Mir war aber auch klar, dass ich... Mein Ziel war dann, ein Portfolio aufzubauen. Ich dachte, ich hab kein Studium und dergleichen, ich komm ja nie in irgendeine Firma runter, wenn ich nicht irgendwas vorweisen kann.
Also wollte ich ganz viele Spiele machen, um zu sagen, ja hier, ich kann Spiele machen. Und Deathwash ist dann eher so zufällig entstanden. So nebenbei, ich hatte dann noch bei jemand anderem mitgeholfen, an dessen Spiel, und dann hatte ich dann abends quasi immer an Grafiken gearbeitet und irgendwann ist dann das Spiel daraus entstanden. Aber als ich das dann gesehen hatte, wusste ich, das ist jetzt das Ding, was ich machen möchte. Okay, ich muss ja trotzdem mal fragen, wovon lebt man denn dann? Also von den Rest aus der Druckerei, Schatzkiste, oder hat man als Spielentwickler? Irgendwann ging das dann in familiäre Unterstützung über, beziehungsweise Unterstützung meiner Frau. Und jetzt musst du mit Death Trash reich berühmt werden?
Ich weiß nicht.
Aber es war ja direkt auch, also bei dem Projekt war zumindest von Tag eins dann irgendwie so ein bisschen Interesse von außen, sodass absehbar war, okay, irgendwann kann man daraus was machen, also entweder in Crowdfunding oder mit einem Publisher zusammenarbeiten. Aber das heißt, das ist, wenn man diesen Weg anstrebt als alleine Einzelkämpfer, dann muss man auch sozusagen in Vorleistung gehen, sag ich mal. Dann wäre es sozusagen gut, eine Schatzkiste zu haben.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Also ich hätte auch nicht gedacht, dass es so lange dauert. Ich hab jetzt so drei Jahre und ich weiß, es wären noch so vielleicht anderthalb Jahre, bis es dann rauskommt. Also ich hätte nie gedacht, dass es dann so lange dauert, aber naja, rückblickend betrachtet natürlich. Okay, und wie bist du dann auf die Idee gekommen, im Saftladen zu arbeiten? Ja, als ich in Berlin ankam, habe ich einige Events hier besucht und dann schon mal die anderen kennengelernt. Und im Internet lernt man sich ja auch kennen über Twitter und dergleichen. Und dann war man irgendwie so auf dem Schirm von den Leuten, glaube ich. Okay, und dann einfach sozusagen gedacht, in einem Kollektiv arbeiten ist gut?
Ja, also für mich auf jeden Fall.
Also ich war vorher nur immer in meinem eigenen Raum, von morgens bis abends. Und das schlug irgendwie so ein bisschen auf die Laune. Verstehe. Jörg, wie war es denn bei dir? Wie bist du zum Spiele machen gekommen?
Ja, also ich bin als Kind in den 80ern aufgewachsen. Da war der C64 das, was man haben wollte. Und den hatte ich nicht. Und den hab ich, ja ganz schlimm. Und das war Teufelszeug und das kam bei uns nicht ins Haus. Und da hab ich angefangen, die Spiele, die ich beim Nachbarn gespielt hab, zu Hause nachzubauen. Mit Papier und so. Und dann so mit zwei Spielern, so einer macht den Computer und der andere macht sozusagen das, was der Computer dann machen würde. Und so ging das los. Und irgendwann hab ich dann schließlich doch mir mehr oder weniger mit meinem eigenen Geld 10, 64 kaufen dürfen. Und hab dann angefangen, ganz furchtbar schlechte Textadventures in Basic zu schreiben. Und als Rache musste meine Familie die dann spielen. Und ja, und dann hab ich, war so ähnlich bei Stefan, ich hab dann einen ganz anderen Weg erst mal, bin dann einen ganz anderen Weg gegangen. Ich hab irgendwie alles Mögliche gemacht und war, weil ich immer auch dachte, um Spielentwickler zu sein, muss man furchtbar gut programmieren können. Und um furchtbar gut programmieren zu können, muss man furchtbar gut in Mathe sein. Und das bin ich nicht und deswegen kann ich das nicht. Und Grafiker kamen auch nicht in Frage. Und war dann über Obenweg. Ich war im Flughafen in Frankfurt eine Zeit lang so, weil Reisen war die andere Sache, die ich cool fand und hab da als Reisekaufbahn gearbeitet. Und da fing es an, dass ich, da hatte man immer so tote Zeiten. So die Nebensaison, so im November oder so, da kommt kein Schwein. Und da saß ich dann mit meinen zwei Rechnern an einem Schalter und auf einem Rechner hab ich angefangen zu modden. Also so, hat echt stundenlang nichts zu tun.
Also Computerspiele zu verändern.
Richtig, genau, also existierende Spiele zu verändern. Und da hab ich mitbekommen, oh, es gibt Leveleditoren. Oh, das kann ich ja. Oh, Skripten, das geht und so, das krieg ich hin. Und das war ziemlich cool und das Paar, also das war ja irgendwie so frühes Internet, so Ende 90er, da hab ich dann hochgeladen und die kamen dann auch ganz gut an. Und da dachte ich, oh, das ist ja ganz cool, vielleicht gibt's da ja doch eine berufliche Perspektive für mich. Und bin dann zwei, dann auch, auch da ging's mir ähnlich wie Stefan. Ich hab irgendwann gedacht, also die Reisebranche hat keine Zukunft, das Internet wird schon immer größer, die Leute, ne wirklich, also die Leute, es ist irgendwie ganz klar, dass das, was ich jetzt hier mache, kann eigentlich ein Computer besser, wenn die Leute dem nur vertrauen. Damals haben sie eben noch nicht vertraut, das war eigentlich dein einziger Vorteil als Mensch. Und bin dann nach Berlin auf die Games Academy damals. Die haben da ganz frisch einen Kurs angeboten als Programmierer. 3D Programming nannte sich das. Und das war 2003, genau. Weil ich dachte, das sei ein guter Weg, um Kontakte zu bekommen. Und um auch was zu lernen. Aber Programmierung konnte ich nicht so gut, hatte ich mir halt nur ein bisschen was beigebracht. Und war dann da 2 Jahre, habe die Ausbildung abgeschlossen und habe dann dabei aber festgestellt, dass ich nicht als Programmierer arbeiten will, also zumindest nicht in erster Linie, sondern ich eigentlich Game Design machen möchte oder Level Design oder was in die Richtung. Also dass für mich Programmierung immer nur Mittel zum Zweck ist und nicht, also ich möchte was erreichen, ich möchte, dass im Spiel etwas bestimmtes passiert und deswegen programmiere ich das. Ich programmiere es nicht, weil ich Programmieren so geil finde. Und dann habe ich mich über verschiedene Jobs auch außerhalb Berlins so den Bogen geschlagen. Ich war dann irgendwie in Kehl am Rhein eine Zeit lang bei einer Firma, habe da gearbeitet. Dann wurde mir sehr schnell klar, ich will wieder in Berlin sein. Und das ist auch der Ort, an dem ich leben möchte. Und dann war ich wieder in Berlin und bin dann auch zu Jäger gekommen. 2007. Die fingen gerade an, ein Spiel zu arbeiten, das hieß Spec Ops The Line.
Will ich noch ganz kurz sagen, ich bin von der Kritik sehr gut besprochener Ego-Shooter, wo es mal als Skandar gewertet wurde, dass der nicht den deutschen Computerspielpreis gewonnen hat.
Ja, okay. Das wäre jetzt gut. Genau, es ist bei der Kritik relativ gut ein ankommendes Spiel, in das auch viel Herzblut reinging, trotz dessen, dass man in einem großen Team gearbeitet hat. Aber ich glaube, wenn man fünf Jahre in so einem Spiel arbeitet, dann hängt man da auch einfach dran. Und ich habe dann so ein bisschen Karriere gemacht bei Jäger. War erst Level Designer, dann Game Designer, dann Lead Level Designer. Und dann kam das nächste Projekt, das war Dead Island 2. Das war auch so ein bisschen mein Baby, weil das war so, das hatte ich gepitcht und das wollte ich unbedingt haben und machen und so. Und dann durfte ich dort Design Director sein, so nannte sich das. Und ich dachte auch cool, das ist irgendwie mein Spiel und ich kann da Director sein, das ist ja super und so. Und hab dann festgestellt, dass mir das nicht so gefällt eigentlich, weil ich gar nicht mehr Spiele mache, sondern nur noch anderen Leuten erzähle, wie sie es machen sollen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, vielleicht können wir an dieser Stelle das kurz einziehen für die Leute, die sich nicht in der Spielbranche so gut auskennen. Du hast gerade diese vier Begriffe gesagt, die klangen wie so eine Leiter. Kannst du das ganz kurz ausmalen, was das bedeutet? Also nicht sagen in aller ebischen Länge, nur so ganz kurz, damit man eine Vorstellung hat, wie das Spielemachen verändert.
Okay, also ich habe als Level-Designer angefangen. Level-Designer sind die Leute, die die Level bauen, die sozusagen die Spielwelt bauen. Kann man sich vorstellen, die laufen wirklich rum und die ziehen die Mauern und ziehen den Boden ein und sagen, hier steht ein Gegner und stellen ihn dann auch da hin. Und machen das sozusagen mit ihren beiden Händen und der Maus. Und dann war ich eben der Lead-Level-Designer, der macht das noch ein bisschen, aber ansonsten erzählt er halt den anderen, wo sie die Sachen hinstellen sollen.
Ist also eher so der Architekt?
Ja, genau, oder der Vorarbeiter.
Der Vorarbeiter. Da steht schon fest, wie das aussehen muss, aber der managt das so ein bisschen.
Und dann der Director, genau, der sagt eigentlich nur noch so, hey, so grob so, das ist die Richtung, wo wir hingehen. Mehr blau. Das hab ich gemacht. Und in der Zeit ging es schon los, dass ich eigentlich nicht mehr so richtig happy war darüber, weil mir eben der eigentliche Kontakt am Spiel gefehlt hat. Weil ich eigentlich in diese Branche gegangen bin und eigentlich diesen Beruf auch ergriffen hab, weil mir das Machen von Spielen mit meinen beiden Händen Spaß macht. Und in der Zeit habe ich schon angefangen, sozusagen Spiele auch wieder, ähnlich wie Stefan, alleine zu Hause Spiele zu machen, kleine, selber zu programmieren und auf so einer Online-Plattform auch ohne die nicht zu verkaufen, sondern kostenlos rauszustellen, einfach damit ich irgendwie noch ein Spiel mache. Und damit ich auch ein Spiel fertig mache, weil das ist ja das andere Ding bei Triple A, die Sachen dauern ja immer ewig.
Also so ein bisschen Kontext zu verleihen. Während er an so einem Zombiespiel gearbeitet hat, hat er an einem Spiel gearbeitet, wo man mit Bienen Blumen bestäubt hat. Also so verzweifelt war Jörg.
Bestimmt, ja voll. Das war cool. Ja, war ein cooles Spiel. Genau, aber so war es wirklich. Und dann ging das in die Brüche. Dann gab es irgendwie auch alle möglichen Probleme. Da haben wir drei Jahre dran gearbeitet. Und dann kam das Spiel nicht raus. Und es gab also Streit zwischen dem Publisher, das ist so der Geldgeber, und der Lizenzhalter und dem Studio. Und der Publisher hat gesagt, wir suchen uns jemand anderes, ihr seid doof und ihr macht das Spiel jetzt nicht zu Ende. Und haben im Prinzip Jäger das Spiel weggenommen, was natürlich auch mal so einen massiven finanziellen Impact hat. Also da wurden irgendwie sehr viele Leute entlassen. Ich nicht, aber viele andere, viele meiner Freunde sozusagen auch. Man ist dann irgendwie acht Jahre befreundet und so sind dann nicht mehr da. Schreibtische leer ist nicht so schön. Und dann hab ich gesagt, nee, das mach ich nicht noch mal. Hab dann mich doch noch mal breitschlagen lassen, noch mal in einem größeren Projekt was zu machen. Und bin dann aber sozusagen über den Umweg schließlich im Saftladen gelandet und hab dann...
Also direkt, du bist direkt sozusagen vom Großprojekt gelandet?
Nee, nicht direkt, ich bin dann noch mal zu einer anderen Firma.
Ich meine direkt von, ich arbeite nicht mehr bei einer Firma in den Saftladen? Oder war dann, ich gehe aus diesem Firmenkonzept raus, sitze erstmal zu Hause und stelle dann fest nach?
Ach so, nee, tatsächlich war es so, ich war dann noch mal kurz bei einem anderen Studio, anderthalb Jahre, und dann sozusagen, und dann wollte ich da aber raus. Und dann war es tatsächlich so, dass ich den Johannes getroffen habe, und der Johannes meinte so, hey, wir ziehen gerade um von unserem Kleinen. Und es war wirklich so, ich hatte da schon länger ein Auge drauf geworfen. Ich hatte die schon irgendwie zwei Jahre bei euch.
Du hast dich ins gemachte Nest gesetzt.
Ja, ja, so war es. Ich dachte, das ist ja cool. Die haben ja hier alles schön eingerichtet. Da ist eigentlich noch Platz für mich.
Genau, Tisch schon da, Stühle schon da.
Verstehe, so war es. Dann bin ich in Saftladen. Da war mir aber auch schon klar, ich will dieses Spiel machen. Ich hatte dieses Konzept, ich hatte das schon länger in der Schublade. Das war tatsächlich eins der Konzepte, was ich gemacht habe in dem Zeitraum, wo ich immer kurze Spiele gemacht habe. Und dann habe ich beschlossen, das wollte ich machen. Und ja, da bin ich seit Anfang 2017 im Saftladen. Genau, und jetzt seit drei Monaten ist der Sebastian dabei. Davor war ich alleine.
Der Johannes. Okay, pass auf, ich versuche das Ganze fast vorwärts zu machen. Also ich hatte nie einen C64, auch nicht. Ich hatte einen 128er.
Oh mein Gott.
Du warst einer von denen.
Meine Eltern haben ja alle Computer und alle Nintendo-Consumer gekauft.
Aber die Belohnung war natürlich, dass sie keine schrecklichen Textadventures spielen mussten.
Stimmt. Das haben sie nie machen müssen.
Liebe Eltern, gebt euren Kindern frühzeitig Zugang zu technischem Gerät. Sonst müsst ihr irgendwann schlechte Textadventures spielen.
Ich werde büßen dafür.
Das ist die Lektion, die man heute aus dem Chaosradio 247 auf jeden Fall schon mal mitnehmen kann.
Genau. Also bei mir haben sie den Fehler nicht gemacht. Ich war trotzdem halt ganz lange auch Konsument, immer Spiele konsumiert. Und wie war denn das dann bei mir? Keine Ahnung. Ja, genau. Ich habe in so einer Webbutze angefangen. Ich bin dann eher Grafiker gewesen und habe dann in so einer Webbutze mit Flash so Navigationselemente gebaut. Und das war dann damals noch Flash 3. Das war diese Ära dieser furchtbaren Websites, die erstmal so ein großes, bildschirmfüllendes Intro abgespielt haben, was man nicht abkürzen konnte. Und dann diese Navigation hatten, wo man eigentlich man wollte nur irgendwo hin navigieren und die haben dann aber so total verspielt, irgendwie einen dazu aufgeführt, jetzt irgendwie einen Ball irgendwo rumzuwerfen oder so. Diese Navigation habe ich gebaut, Entschuldigung. Verbrecher. Aber das hat dann auch dazu geführt, dass ich da irgendwie angefangen habe, interaktive Spiele zu machen für diese Firma. Und die hat sich dann komplett umgemodelt und hat dann eigentlich eine Zeit lang nur noch Spiele gemacht. Und ich habe die komplett größtenteils umgesetzt. Also von Grafik über Coden, jetzt mache ich Anführungszeichen, hier Radioleute, weil ich bin wirklich kein Coder. Das ist unglaublich schlimm. Aber ich habe es trotzdem gemacht. Aber ich bin noch schlimmer als Jörg.
Also jetzt stapelt der aber tief. Der macht auch schon komplizierte logische Sachen mit seiner Arbeit.
Das ist lieb, dass du das sagst. Aber wenn du den Codes, okay, ist egal. Auf jeden Fall habe ich da alles gemacht. Das fand ich extrem cool. Aber die haben mich nicht lange halten können. Da kam dann auch irgendwann die Ernüchterung, das läuft alles nicht so gut. Und dann bin ich genau wie Jörg auch auf die Games Academy. Da haben wir uns dann auch das erste Mal kennengelernt. Allerdings war ich dann in diesem Game Art und Animation Kurs. Da sind wir dann auch zusammengezogen in der Zeit. Da haben wir eine WG zusammen gehabt, der Jörg und ich. Das war eine wilde Zeit. Mit anderen Leuten auch noch. Und dann habe ich auch noch mal eine kurze Exkursion gehabt nach Süddeutschland, fast in die Heimat. Im Schwarzwald war ich da eine Zeit lang. In Fillingen-Schwenningen, wunderschönes Örtchen. Ganz toll.
Also dann Computerspiele oder was anderes?
So was, Computerspieleinliches, naja, das war ein Computerspiel. Na gut, reden wir nicht drüber. Aber da ich schon damals, als ich hier in Berlin war, meine zukünftige Frau kennengelernt habe, wollte ich dann auf jeden Fall wieder zurück und habe das dann auch geschafft über Jaeger. Die haben mich dann da eingestellt. Und da war ich dann auch eine ganze Zeit lang. Da habe ich dann auch mit Jörg zusammengearbeitet. Und habe dann aber frühzeitig, noch bevor Dead Island 2 dann sozusagen Jaeger verlassen hat, habe ich dann Jaeger verlassen, weil ich dann auch irgendwann zusammen mit Riad gemerkt habe, wir wollen irgendwie was anderes machen. Wir wollen so ein bisschen raus aus dieser großen Maschinerie und so ein bisschen kleinere, persönlichere Dinge machen. Und haben dann Maschinenmensch gegründet, haben mit dem Konzept von Curious Expedition das Medienboard Berlin Brandenburg davon überzeugen können, uns Geld zu geben.
Dazu kommen wir nochmal in Detail wieder.
Ja, gerne. Und haben wir dann losgelegt und haben dann das erste Jahr von zu Hause ausgearbeitet. Wir haben dann relativ schnell festgestellt, es geht zwar über Skype und so, dass man sich ab und zu sieht, aber ein persönliches Treffen ist doch immer gut. Deswegen waren wir dann immer montags und freitags bei Riad im Wohnzimmer und das war ganz okay. Aber wir haben natürlich gemerkt, wenn man aus so einer Umgebung kommt, wo man mit über 100 Leuten aus allen möglichen kulturellen Kreisen zusammenarbeitet, was bei Jaeger der Fall war, auf einmal so übertragenden Sinne bei Riad im Wohnzimmer, in der Unterhose sitzt, haben wir schnell gemerkt, das geht so nicht.
Hättet euch schon auch was ansehen können.
Ja, aber wenn man mal unter sich ist, wäre erst mal komfortabel. Auf jeden Fall haben wir recht schnell gemerkt, wir wollen irgendwie gucken. Dann gab es noch andere Komponenten. Wir haben uns in der Berliner Szene umgeguckt und haben gesehen, es gibt so viele Events, wo die Szene temporär zusammenkommt, aber es gibt nichts, wo sozusagen Permanenz da ist. Dann haben wir gedacht, wäre doch eigentlich ganz cool, wenn man so ein Kollektiv gründen könnte. Dann haben wir das angefangen. Aber es hat ganz schön lange gedauert.
Okay, stopp, an dieser Stelle machen wir eine kurze Pause. Alles klar, es hat ganz schön lange gedauert. Wir werden gleich aus Furcht drüber sprechen, was der Saftladen eigentlich ist. Vorher hören wir eine kleine Musik, die kommt jetzt aus Through the Darkest of Times. Das heißt Gloomy Sandy, von wem ist die? Wie habt ihr das gemacht?
Das ist ein altes, mittlerweile lizenzfreies Stück von einem tschechischen Piatisten.
Ist die ganze Musik aus dem Spiel so?
Wahrscheinlich ja.
Wir hören auf jeden Fall erstmal rein. Wir haben hier den Glumisunday aus dem noch festzustellen Computerspiele Through the Darkest of Times und wenn ihr jetzt gerade zuguckt, werdet ihr feststellen, oh mein Gott, das Sofa ist leer. Alle sind geflüchtet, keinesfalls. Wir haben aber noch ein anderes Thema, was in den letzten Wochen wichtig war und zu dem wir nicht das ganze Chaos Radio machen, von dem wir aber gedacht haben, da solltet ihr wenigstens etwas bei uns auch gehört haben. Und da geht es um eine neue EU-Gesetzgebung, um Uploadfilter, um Leistungsschutzrecht, um sogar eine Zensurmaschine und was das alles genau miteinander zu tun hat, wird euch jetzt erklärt von Helena.
Am 20. Juni hat der Rechtsausschuss des Europäischen Parlaments eine Urheberrechtsreform verabschiedet, die in Netz und Medien kontrovers diskutiert wird. Ein zentraler Bestandteil dieser Reform soll Verlagen, Plattenfirmen und anderen Verwertungsgesellschaften zugutekommen. Aber es gehen handfeste Gefahren für die Freiheit des Netzes von dem Vorschlag aus. Julia Reeder sitzt als Abgeordnete für die Piratenpartei im EU-Parlament und erklärt, wo sie Probleme in der Reform sieht.
Das ist einerseits der Artikel 13 zu Upload-Filtern und andererseits der Artikel 11 mit dem sogenannten Leistungsschutzrecht für Presseverleger. Beide diese Artikel haben zu großen Protesten geführt, weil sie das Internet in ihren Grundfunktionsweisen angreifen. Also ursprünglich das Ziel dieses Artikel 13 war, einen Streit zwischen Musikindustrie und YouTube beizulegen, dass YouTube eben für die Musik, die dort hochgeladen wird, die YouTube auch monetarisiert, die Verwertungsgesellschaften nicht entsprechend vergütet. Und das ist denke ich auch durchaus irgendwie ein berechtigtes Anliegen. Aber das Problem ist, dass dieser Artikel 13 wirklich weit über das Ziel hinaus schießt und auch absolut kontraproduktive Maßnahmen enthält, wie dieser Upload-Filter. Nach diesem Vorschlag werden so gut wie alle Online-Plattformen, wo User Inhalte hochladen und öffentlich machen können, direkt haftbar für alle Urheberrechtsverletzungen ihrer Nutzer. Und sie wären zusätzlich dazu verpflichtet, Maßnahmen zu ergreifen, dass Urheberrechtsverletzungen gar nicht erst stattfinden. Das heißt mit anderen Worten, ihnen bliebe gar nichts anderes übrig, als die Installation von automatischen Filtern. Teilweise kennen wir diese Filter schon. YouTube's Content ID löscht alle nase lang legale Inhalte, weil diese Filter überhaupt nicht in der Lage sind, zu erkennen, wer tatsächlich der rechtmäßige Rechteinhaber ist. Und ob es sich vielleicht um eine legale Parodie oder ein Zitat handelt. Gerade diese Woche hat z.B. der britische Schauspieler Stephen Fry ein Video von sich selbst verlinken wollen, das dann plötzlich in Großbritannien gesperrt war.
Damit könnte sich ein Urheberrechtsschutz in eine Zensurmaschine verwandeln. Außerdem enthält der Vorschlag auch etwas, das man in Deutschland schon fast als Gescheitheit angesehen hatte. Die Wiederkehr des Leistungsschutzrechts. Und das ist keinem Deut besser geworden, erklärt Julia Rehder.
Bei Artikel 11 geht es nicht um das Hochladen von Inhalten, sondern um das Verlinken von Presseartikeln. Nach diesem Artikel würde ein neues Recht für Presseverleger geschaffen, das selbst für die kleinsten Ausschnitte aus Presseartikeln gelten würde. Also Journalisten haben bereits ein Urheberrecht an ihren Artikeln. Das gilt aber nicht für ganz einfache, rein faktische Sätze, wie zum Beispiel Angela Merkel trifft Theresa May. Wenn man aber im Internet einen Presseartikel verlinken will, dann muss man zumindest die Überschrift dieses Artikels irgendwie verwenden können, denn sonst wissen die User ja überhaupt nicht, was sich hinter diesem Link verbirgt. Insofern stellt dieser Vorschlag eine große Gefahr für die Informationsfreiheit dar, zumal es wirklich mildere Alternativvorschläge geht, nach denen die Verleger unmittelbar gegen tatsächliche Urheberrechtsverletzungen an Presseartikeln vorgehen könnten. Sie könnten damit auch die Presseartikel gegenüber Online-Plattformen wie zum Beispiel Facebook lizenzieren, ohne erst alle einzelnen Urheber um Erlaubnis fragen zu müssen. Aber was absolut gar nicht geht, ist eben so ein Leistungsschutzrecht, das selbst Inhalte schützt, die urheberrechtlich gar nicht geschützt sind.
Der Rechtsausschuss hat beide Artikel angenommen. Die Upload-Filter sind mit 13 zu 12 Stimmen denkbar knapp durchgegangen. Für das Leistungsschutzrecht gab es noch weniger Bedenkenträger. Auch wenn das im Gesetzgebungsprozess der EU ein wichtiger Schritt ist, den viele als entscheidend ansehen, muss das Gesetz noch vor das EU-Parlament. Damit gibt es noch eine weitere Möglichkeit, das Vorhaben aufzuhalten, wie Julia Rehder erklärt.
Wenn die Abgeordneten in dieser Abstimmung dem Ausschussmandat zustimmen, dann können sofort Verhandlungen mit dem Rat über diese Richtlinie beginnen. Leider hat auch der Rat, also die nationalen Regierungen, dem Leistungsschutzrecht und den Upload-Filtern zugestimmt. Das heißt, dann gibt es kaum noch eine Möglichkeit, das Ganze zu stoppen. Wenn aber die Mehrheit im Plenum mit Nein stimmt, dann haben wir die Möglichkeit, noch mal neue Änderungsanträge einzureichen und die schädlichsten Teile dieser Urheberrechtsreform zu entfernen. Deshalb ist es ganz wichtig, dass alle jetzt ihre Abgeordneten zu dieser Abstimmung am 4. und 5. Juli aufrufen, dort mit Nein zu stimmen. Denn viele Abgeordnete, die nicht im Rechtsausschuss sitzen, haben sich in der Vergangenheit gar nicht so intensiv mit dem Thema Urheberrecht beschäftigt. Und auf den ersten Blick sieht das vielleicht erst mal vernünftig aus, dass man sagt, man möchte Urheber im Netz besser schützen. Aber Fakt ist, dass diese Vorschläge von Menschenrechtsaktivisten, von Wissenschaftlern usw. wirklich massiv kritisiert werden. Und sie letzten Endes eher zum Aufbau einer Zensurinfrastruktur führen, als dass tatsächlich Urheberinnen und Urheber damit größere Einnahmen erwarten können.
Falls ihr also noch helfen wollt, Uploadfilter und Leistungsschutzrecht zu stoppen, kontaktiert eure Abgeordneten. Wie das genau geht, wird auf saviourinternet.eu beschrieben.
Ihr wisst also, was ihr zu tun habt. Und damit herzlich willkommen zurück zur zweiten Hälfte des Chaosradios 247 mit Stefan Höfelbrink, Jörg Friedrich und Johannes Christmann. Hallo. Hallo. Wir haben euch in der ersten halben Stunde ausführlich vorstellen lassen, also wir wissen jetzt, wer ihr seid, was ihr macht und wo ihr herkommt. Und das gemeinsame Ding, weswegen ihr aber auch heute hier seid, ist ja der Saftladen Berlin. Wir haben schon irgendwie gehört, das nennt es ein Gaming-Kollektiv, es ist euer Arbeitsplatz, ihr arbeitet da zusammen. Aber jetzt noch mal ganz genau erklärt, was ist eigentlich der Saftladen? Also was ist die Idee dahinter? Warum seid ihr darauf gekommen, das genau so zu machen, wie es funktioniert, außer dass ihr nicht mehr in Riads Wohnzimmer sitzen wolltet, in Unterhosen?
Schlecht war es nicht. Also da stecken viele Sachen dahinter. Ich denke mal, grundlegendste Idee ist, dass wir daran glauben, dass, wenn man gemeinsam zusammensitzt und auch mal den Blick auf andere Projekte, andere kreative Schaffenswerke und Auseinandersetzungen richten kann, hilft einem das selber auch ganz viel, dass man mal so ein bisschen rauskommt aus seiner Denke. Außerdem hatte das eben, das habe ich schon vorhin kurz erwähnt, haben wir gesehen, dass das in der Berliner Szene, die eigentlich recht stark ist, was so die unabhängige Spieleentwicklung angeht, fehlte das. Da gab es ganz viele Events, wo man temporär zusammen kam und sich ausgetauschen konnte, aber danach gingen alle wieder nach Hause und man hatte nie so einen Anlaufpunkt, wo man hingehen kann, wo man weiß, da trifft man immer jemanden an. Oder wenn Leute die Stadt besucht haben, dass die auf einen Schlag irgendwie mal mehrere Spieleentwickler aus einem unabhängigen Bereich treffen konnten.
Aber vielleicht jetzt mal, was ist denn das genau? Ihr nennt das Kollektiv, als wir den Sendungsteaser geschrieben haben, hatten wir zuerst das Wort Co-Working Space. Das stimmt ja nicht. Da kann ja nicht jeder einfach kommen und einen Tisch mieten.
Theoretisch funktioniert es wie ein Co-Working Space.
Und praktisch, was ist also der Unterschied?
Praktisch ist der Unterschied der größte, dass wir eigentlich permanent ausgebucht sind und keine Leute annehmen können, weil wir nicht genug Platz haben. Außerdem gehen die Leute nicht einen Monat rein und dann wieder raus oder so. Und wir müssen leider auch einen Auswahlprozess machen, wen wir in den Saftladen mit reinnehmen. Insofern ist es schon so ein bisschen eher ein kuratierter Co-Working Space.
Ich würde den Unterschied vielleicht zwischen Standard Co-Working Space ist ein bisschen wie Airbnb zu einer WG. Also in der WG suchst du dir ja aus, wer da mit reinkommt. Man hat, also es gibt ja so totale Zweck-WGs, aber in den meisten WGs hat man da noch ein bisschen was miteinander zu tun und kocht vielleicht mal zusammen. Und es ist halt eben auch eine Gemeinschaft und nicht nur, nicht nur ich habe hier das Zimmer gemietet.
Könntest du mal wieder abspülen, fällt mir gerade ein.
Ich habe doch erst.
Was sind zum Beispiel die Kriterien? Also wenn ihr sagt, ihr wollt nur bestimmte Leute da haben oder ihr sucht das schon aus, nach welchen Kriterien wird denn da kuratiert? Das klingt total nett übrigens, kuratieren, wenn es um Leute geht.
Das ist situationsabhängig. So ein bisschen. Also jetzt momentan zum Beispiel eigentlich nur noch Menschen, die uns mit unserer Diversitätsquote helfen zum Beispiel. Also wir hatten jetzt gerade erst überlegt, ob wir eine Gruppe von drei Entwicklern mit reinnehmen. Es waren aber auch alles drei Kerle und dann haben wir gesagt, ne sorry. Also wir sind sowieso voll. Wir hätten vielleicht noch Platz machen können, aber wie wir eingangs schon erwähnt haben, wir haben so ein bisschen immer noch die Problematik, dass es halt hauptsächlich weiße Männer sind, die an Spielen arbeiten oder auch im Saftladen bei uns zumindest sind. Ein paar Frauen haben wir, aber das ist noch nicht genug. Insofern, das ist zum Beispiel für uns momentan die Hauptauswahl. Ansonsten geht's grob darum.
Aber schon auf jeden Fall Spieleentwicklerinnen. Ja, grob.
Also müssen nicht unbedingt alle Spieleentwickler sein. Also wir haben auch Leute, die jetzt nicht direkt an Spielen arbeiten. Zum Beispiel Lorenzo Pilia, das ist ein Italiener, der hier in Berlin lebt und arbeitet. Der ist eher tätig im Bereich Eventmanagement und der ist zum Beispiel bei der Amaze, der Programmdirektor. Oder ist der Organisator von Talk and Play, das ist ein super wichtiges Community-Event für Spiele-Machende hier in Berlin. Aber selber macht er eigentlich nicht hauptsächlich Spiele.
Aber alle, die da sind, haben schon was mit Spielen zu tun?
Die haben schon im Ferntesten mindestens was mit Spielen zu tun, ja.
Und das heißt, wenn man reingeht in den Saftladen, dann ist das tatsächlich wie in der WG, man zieht da ein für unbestimmte Zeit und nicht auf den Monat.
Man sollte nicht da schlafen. Auch wenn das Jörg Reisig oft macht, lieber Jörg. Apropos, wenn das weiter so geht, müssen wir die Gebühren für dich erhöhen. Aber eigentlich schläft man nicht da.
Das ist auch ein Problem, das man auch aus Hacker Spaces kennt. Der Saftladen ist ein Ort, in dem man langfristig zusammenarbeitet. Wie ist das konkret? Wir müssen uns das eigentlich vorstellen. Hacker Space, also hier in Berlin, der Club ist, wenn jetzt nicht gerade Chaosradio ist, wo tatsächlich drei Stuhlreihen vor einem Sofa stehen, ist ja, war salopp gesagt, ein großer Tisch, wo man rumsitzen kann und ein paar Sofas, die so ein bisschen noch rumschieben, wo man auch draufsitzen kann. Was ist der Saftladen?
Ein großer Raum, den man Tisch haben kann, wenn man möchte. Ansonsten bringt man ihn selber mit, das ist auch möglich. Also es sind vor allen Dingen Arbeitsplätze.
Also es ist eher Büroatmosphäre als jetzt so eine loungeige, wie hier, würde ich sagen.
Wie ist das, weil du auch gerade gesagt hast, das soll ja auch Anlaufpunkt sein, wenn man in der Stadt ist, aus der Szene kommt und mal sozusagen Leute treffen will. Es gibt hier beim Chaos Computer Club Berlin, gibt es zum Beispiel einen offenen Donnerstag, da kann man einfach sozusagen, wenn man sich auch nur am ran interessiert und nur mal gucken will, wie das aussieht, kann man einfach kommen. Gibt es auch was beim Saftladen auch, dass ihr sagt, man kann bei uns eigentlich immer vorbeikommen, mal gucken, wo muss man sich da anmelden oder macht ihr sowas gar nicht. Gibt ihr, keine Ahnung, zweimal im Jahr so ein Event oder?
Also dadurch, dass schon die Leute auch wirklich konzentriert arbeiten, ist es schon auch eher so, dass wir vorher mal Kontakt aufnehmen haben sollten. Also wir haben alle zwei Wochen zum Beispiel machen wir den Social Club, nennen wir das. Das ist ein, wo wir zusammenkommen, zum Beispiel morgen wieder, jeden zweiten Freitag. Da sitzen wir dann ab sechs rum und unterhalten uns, machen so ein bisschen Stuhlkreis, hat so ein bisschen was von einer Selbsthilfegruppe für Spieleentwickler.
Trage ich Hosen oder nicht?
Genau, trage ich Hosen oder nicht. Was für Spiele habe ich in meiner Jugend gespielt? Nein, aber da erzählen wir so ein bisschen auch, was uns umtreibt, auch außerhalb vom Spiele machen. Weil wir einfach auch wollen, wir wollen mehr über die Menschen erfahren und wollen über einfach nur ein gemeinsames Nebeneinander herarbeiten, uns auch kennenlernen. Und da kann man auch gut vorbeikommen und da haben wir oft auch Gäste zum Beispiel. Aber auch hier mit uns Kontakt aufnehmen. Man kann immer jederzeit saftladen.berlin auf die Webseite gehen und da gibt es ein Kontaktformular oder ihr könnt uns direkt anschreiben. Und da machen wir gerne was mit jedem aus. Also wir haben immer wieder gerne Gäste und lernen gerne neue Leute kennen.
Und gibt es irgendwie so, wie soll man sagen, Zukunftsplanung oder sowas? Das hört sich für mich an, also wir brauchen einen Ort und der Ort soll uns eine Arbeitatmosphäre bieten und es möglich machen, mit anderen gleichgesinnten Menschen zusammenzuarbeiten. Und wenn sich das so ein bisschen trägt, dann ist das okay. Jetzt hast du gerade gesagt, bei deinem Spiel kannst du nie loslassen, du musst immer weiter feilen. Ist der Saftladen jetzt was, wo du denkst oder wo ihr denkt, das ist super, ich habe so einen Platz zum Arbeiten und der ist auch eher wie eine nette WG und nicht sozusagen wie so ein Bürokäfig. Ist es das jetzt oder soll das so ein Spiele-Hub Berlin werden, die Indie-Manage?
Ja, da muss man vorsichtig sein. Das Spiele-Hub geht dann gleich los mit Inkubatoren und so ein Kram und da tun wir uns so ein bisschen schwierig. Also wir wollen ja schon auch aufpassen, dass die Seele bleibt und dass das beibehält, was das eigentlich ausmacht. Auf der anderen Seite natürlich ist der Wunsch da, dass da mehr draus wird, dass wir momentan eine Momentaufnahme haben auf einem Weg, wo wir mittelfristig vielleicht so ein paar Ideen haben, aber langfristig nicht wirklich wissen, wo es hingeht. Also es passieren auf jeden Fall immer mehr Dinge gemeinschaftlich. Wir haben jetzt zum Beispiel die ersten Workshops gemeinsam gemacht, hier einmal einer BTK, eine ganze Woche lang zusammen mit… Genau, eine Fachhochschule hier in Berlin.
Also nicht für euch, sondern für Studenten.
Für Studenten haben wir einen Workshop gestaltet. Da ist der Jongor, der ist dort ein Professor, auf uns zugekommen hat, hat gemeint, hey, wollen wir nicht mal eine Woche lang Saftladen-Workshop machen? Und dann haben wir hier Stefan zum Beispiel auch, verschiedene Leute aus dem Saftladen zu verschiedenen Themen eine ganze Woche lang Unterricht dort gegeben, aber bunt gemischt. Aber es war halt alles so ein bisschen eingefärbt durch Saftladen. Es hatte schon so einen Grundtenor, hauptsächlich die Independent Games und meistens so ein bisschen unabhängig kleine Ansätze an verschiedenste Themenbereiche, die irgendwie meistens wieder mit Spielen zu tun hatten. Oder dass wir zusammen Gamejams machen. Es sind auch schon Spiele entstanden, die halt einfach eine Kollaboration waren aus verschiedenen verschiedenen Studios, das ist jetzt nicht so häufig. Auch keins von diesen Spielen ist jetzt irgendwie groß kommerziell geworden, außer eins, was in Kanada ein erfolgreiches Hockeyspiel geworden ist. Aber ne, also das wächst noch und da haben wir auch schon Ideen und viele Perspektiven. Das Problem, an das wir immer geraten, ist halt ein räumliches Problem. Wir sind jetzt schon wieder ausgebucht. Jetzt schon haben sozusagen Firmen, die bei uns drinsitzen, ein Problem mit Wachstum. Wenn wir jetzt noch mehr Leute haben wollen, zum Beispiel Maschinenmensch, wir wollen jetzt demnächst wachsen. Was wir dann machen müssen, ist jetzt gucken, wer geht aus dem Saftladen vielleicht mal raus mittelfristig, langfristig, verlassen dann doch ab und zu mal Leute den Laden. Und da müssen wir gleich den Finger drauf halten und sagen, wir können jetzt keine neuen reinnehmen, weil wir brauchen jetzt wieder Plätze für wahrscheinlich Angestellte, die wir jetzt zum Beispiel erst bekommen.
Seid ihr alles so ein, zwei, drei Mann Teams, oder gibt es auch größere oder kleiner? Geht ja gar nicht.
Also die größte Firma ist Studio Firsbin. Die haben glaube ich zehn Menschen, direkt gefolgt von Maschinenmensch mit vier. Und dann geht es hier so zwei Teams und dann viele Einzelleute.
Wie ist das denn eigentlich mit dem Geld? Also bei Hackspace ist es ja häufig so, da wird ein Verein gegründet oder sowas, dann zahlen da sehr viele Leute irgendwie Mitgliedsbeiträge, dann kriegt man das irgendwie so geregelt. Wie ist das bei euch? Gibt es da einfach sozusagen einen Preis für einen Arbeitsplatz, muss ich da zahlen? Oder habt ihr auch so eine soziale Komponente, dass ihr sagt, okay Einzelkämpfer, dem es gerade nicht so gut geht, muss vielleicht weniger zahlen? Oder ist das da eine Grenze, wo ihr sagt Business, oder ist das auch so, dass man da das anders macht?
Also, die Sache ist die Studio Fisbin und meine Firma Maschinenmensch. Wir haben einfach einen Mietvertrag mit der GSG. Das ist die Hausverwaltung, wo wir unser Büro haben. Und wir tragen diese Kosten und wir vermieten das dann unter an die jeweiligen Personen. Sprich, wir können jetzt nicht den Tisch umsonst hergeben, weil dann müssen wir das extra tragen. Die Rechnung war schon so anfangs gemacht, dass wir sozusagen gestrichen da rauskommen, keiner legt drauf, alle zahlen irgendwie ähnlich viel und wir haben alle den gemeinsamen Vorteil des Zusammensetzens. Was natürlich auch für die Firmen ein relativ großes Risiko ist. Also erstens mal mussten wir Kautionen bezahlen und wenn jetzt Ausfälle sind, also jetzt mal total verrückt, nächsten Monat auf einmal steigen alle aus oder so und dann sitzen wir da und müssen Miete zahlen und können das eigentlich nicht. Also wir gefährden eigentlich unsere Firma in einem Feld, was komplett fremd ist von normalerweise gehen independent Spielefirmen ja an anderen Sachen, Bankrott und nicht an irgendwelchen Fehlenden.
Dann ist es gescheitert, alle sind ausgezogen.
Also schon auch ein Risiko für uns und das tragen wir auch komplett alleine. Hätte man Hosen tragen sollen, aber das ist auch keine Lösung.
Nee, Hosen tragen ist definitiv keine Lösung. Also Kindern frühzeitig Zugang zur Technik geben und keine Hosen tragen. Wir kriegen noch so eine Liste zusammen heute an den wirklich wichtigen Dingen, die für das Game Design wichtig sind. Ich möchte mal ein bisschen beim Geld bleiben und vom Saftladen wieder einen Schritt weggehen, weil das muss ja tatsächlich irgendwo herkommen. Wir haben von Stefan am Anfang schon gehört, da geht man sozusagen in Vorleistung. Aber hast du eine Idee, also andersherum gefragt, du arbeitest an einem Spiel Death Trash. Und bist du jetzt seit drei Jahren und dann sozusagen kommst du in eineinhalb Jahren vielleicht raus. Ist da die Hoffnung, dass es sozusagen so ein Riesenhit wird, dass es die letzten fünf Jahre kompensiert? Oder wie finanziert man sich als Spieleentwickler?
Also, ich bin da wirklich noch so mittendrin und ich hab's halt bis jetzt noch nicht geschafft, so das zu finanzieren.
Aber es war von Anfang an so der Gedanke da oder man hat schon erkannt, das Spiel ist irgendwie, das trifft auf Interesse.
Deswegen war das halt so immer schon die Idee, vielleicht mach ich ein Crowdfunding damit und darauf dann die ganze Zeit hingearbeitet. Aber man ist auch die ganze Zeit mit einigen Publishern im Gespräch.
Es gibt ja verschiedene Publisher, die sich für solche Projekte interessieren. Vielleicht könnt ihr das auch sagen, aber kannst du erst mal erläutern, für die Leute, die gar nicht wissen, was das heißt, was bedeutet das denn, wenn man mit einem Publisher in einen Vertrag abschließt? Gibt der einem dann vorher Geld, damit man das Spiel fertig macht? Oder sagt der nur, wenn du es fertig hast, kümmern wir uns ums Marketing? Oder was genau passiert da eigentlich?
Ich glaube, da gibt es die verschiedensten Abmachungen und Verträge.
Aber recht häufig, zumindest früher war es sehr häufig so, dass der Publisher die Entwicklung bezahlt. Und sobald das Spiel rauskommt, kriegen halt beide Parteien ihren bestimmten Prozentsatz.
Okay, dann wird der Publisher wahrscheinlich erst mal gucken, dass der seine Ausgaben wieder reinkriegt.
Genau, das ist auch sehr häufig, dass der erst mal seine Ausgaben wieder reinholt und danach von dem Reingewinnen dann zieht er dann auch seine Prozente.
Und jetzt hast du gesagt, Crowdfunding ist so eine Überlegung. Ist das mittlerweile ein Standardweg, sein Spiel zu finanzieren? Oder ist das so ein bisschen wie Glottospielen? Also ich kann mir das schwer vorstellen, weil von außen hört man ja eigentlich immer nur von den Spielen, die irgendwann rauskommen, wo gesagt, ja, das war übrigens dieser Crowdfunding-Erfolg, der damals irgendwie eigentlich nur 50.000 Dollar wollte, aber vier Millionen bekommen hat und jetzt 20 Jahre entwickelt wurde. Trag ich mich zu sagen, ist das die Regel? Man geht halt Crowdfunding und dann wird das halt finanziert? Oder ist es eher so, naja, also das kann man probieren, aber es ist eher auch so, kann ich mir auch ein Lotto-Ticket kaufen?
Na, also man kann nicht alles mit Sicherheit sagen, aber oft kann man schon so ein bisschen einschätzen, könnte das ungefähr eine bestimmte Anzahl an Leuten schon interessieren, dass die dann direkt jetzt schon Geld dafür eher geben. Also Stefan würde wahrscheinlich vier Millionen bekommen.
Wie machst du das eigentlich so? Hast du dieses Spiel, gibt es da schon sozusagen so eine Art Beta-Version, die man irgendwie ausprobieren kann? Oder woher weißt du, dass es auf Interesse stößt? Hast du einen YouTube-Trailer, der 50 Millionen Klicks bekommen hat?
Nein, leider nicht. Nein, also ich war von Tag eins an mit dem Spiel online, auf Twitter zum Beispiel. Also als ich noch gar nicht wusste, dass es jetzt mein Spiel werden wird, habe ich einfach schon die Grafiken, an denen ich gearbeitet habe, immer von Tag eins an hochgeladen.
Und alles davor verblasst auf einmal gegen die Zahlen, die ich damit bekommen habe. Und dann wusste man, da ist irgendwas.
Twitter Celebrity.
Aber Leute, Twitter ist doch zu was gut.
Ja, natürlich, von Spielen auf jeden Fall. Ja, und dann über die drei Jahre jetzt natürlich so ein bisschen angesammelt, auch ein Publikum.
So dass ich mir denke, wenn ich jetzt ein Quad-Fanling versuchen würde, wird es zumindest so eine bestimmte Menge. Ja, okay, also du würdest nicht bei null anfangen? Jörg, wo kriegt ihr, ihr habt ja dieses Spiel, man arbeitet da nicht mit Spiel, woher kommt das Geld?
Also wir sind glücklicherweise vom Medienboard Berlin-Brandenburg gefördert worden. Das ist eine Wirtschaftsförderung, das heißt, das ist eigentlich ein Kredit, den wir aber nur im Erfolgsfall zurückzahlen müssen. Wie praktisch.
Es ist ein bedingt zurückzahlbares Darlehen, um genau zu sagen.
Es ist ein bedingt... Es ist kein Kredit. Ich merke schon. Genau, es ist ein bedingt zurückzahlbares Darlehen.
Ja, richtig. Genau.
Dass man zurückzahlen muss, und zwar auch erst dann, wenn man seine eigenen Kosten wieder rein bekommen hat. Es ist aber so, dass man das nur bekommt, wenn man das gegenfinanziert. Also man bekommt sozusagen die Summe, die man selber gegenfinanziert, oder bis zu bekommt man als Darlehen.
Wie kommt man da ran? Ich meine, es ist der Wunsch, wenn man sich den Spieleentwickler als Warstel aufbaut. Man versenkt immer noch das eigene Geld, das man aufbringen musste, aber 50 Prozent vom Topf werden übernommen.
Ja, es ist total super. Man muss sich bewärmen. Es funktioniert ungefähr wie eine Filmförderung. Es gibt einen ganz kleinen Teil, ich glaube, fünf Prozent dessen, was für Filme ausgegeben wird, wird auch für Spiele ausgegeben. Das reicht ja auch. Das entspricht ja auch ungefähr dem Marktanteil, oder? Das wird sich auch nicht ändern, solange das so bleibt. Genau, das Medienboard ist sehr aktiv. Die sind tatsächlich auch auf diesen Game-Veranstaltungen. Es gibt das Talk and Play in Berlin. Das ist eine Veranstaltung alle zwei Monate. Die ist kostenlos, kann jeder hinkommen. Da gibt es einmal Talks. Indie-Entwickler aus der Umgebung stellen ihre Spiele vor. Die kann man dann spielen. Hence Talk and Play. Dort zum Beispiel ist das Medienboard auch da sehr häufig und spricht dann auch direkt Entwickler und Entwicklerinnen an und sagt so, hey, gutes Spiel habt ihr da. Bewerbt euch doch mal bei uns.
Das wird auf jeden Fall ein Erfolg. Die Chancen, dass wir unser bedingt rückzahlbares Darlehen zurückbezahlt bekommen und die Bedingungen erfüllt werden, ist relativ hoch. Oder machen die sowas auch wie, das sieht künstlerisch wertvoll aus?
Ich glaube, die wollen die Mischung. Es ist so ähnlich wie bei der Filmförderung. Die wollen Sachen, die einen gewissen Anspruch haben und interessant sind. Das ist mein Eindruck. Ich sitze ja nicht im Gremium, keine Ahnung. Ich habe das einfach nur Glück gehabt. Aber mein Eindruck ist, die möchten gerne Dinge, die interessant sind irgendwie. Und gleichzeitig aber auch, die einen gewissen wirtschaftlichen Erfolg versprechen.
80% zahlen nicht zurück, habe ich gerade neulich wieder gehört. Zurückzahlen ist die Ausnahme eher. Da achten sie zum Glück nicht so sehr drauf, dass es jetzt wirklich... Also es muss kommerziell aufgestellt sein. Leider ist es nicht wirklich so eine reine Kunstförderung. Das gibt es gar nicht, soweit ich weiß. Rein für Spiele. Also man muss schon auch so eine Absicht der Gewinnein oder der Gewinn des Gewinnes haben. Aber es ist definitiv nicht im Hauptblickfeld eine Förderentscheidung.
Okay, wir sprechen gleich noch über Maschinenmensch, die auch gefordert wurden, die die Bedingungen erfüllt haben und deswegen das Darlehen zurückgezählt haben. Wie es dazu kam, das besprechen wir gleich. Wir hören noch eine kleine Musik, die kommt auch aus dem Saftladen, aber nicht von euch, sondern die kommt aus All Walls Must Fall und ist von der Almut Schwacke, die auch schon bei euch mit ist. Der Song The Next Stop heißt er und ist wie gesagt in diesem anderen Spiel drin. Das war das aus All Walls Must Fall. Wir sind hier immer noch mit den Saftladenleuten, Johannes, Jörg und Stefan und reden jetzt, wo die Sendung fast schon wieder vorbei ist, über das Geld.
Echt jetzt?
Ja, es geht schnell, ne? Zwei Stunden sind nicht viel. Wir haben gerade darüber gelesen, wo das Geld herkommen kann und da kann man sich zum Beispiel fördern lassen und die Förderung ist kein Kredit, sondern ein, wie heißt es?
Bedingt zurückzahlbares Darlehen.
Ein Bedingt zurückzahlbares Darlehen und Maschinenmensch, ihr habt der Curious Expedition, seid da gefördert worden und Stefan, was?
Ja, darf ich noch eben einwerfen?
Ja, bitte. Also, mein Fall noch abzuschießen, ich habe mich da auch beworben, habe auch noch Zusage bekommen, aber bei mir ist das halt noch in der, es fehlt noch die Implementierung, also ich hatte den Eigenanteil noch nicht sicher.
Deswegen ist es in der Mache. Du musst den Eigenanteil noch besorgen und dann würden sie dich fördern? Ja, das wollte ich zu meinem Fall dann noch. Kann man auch so was machen, wir machen jetzt das Crowdfunding und haben dann den Eigenanteil und dann das so?
Den hatte ich in der Kalkulation mit eingerechnet, ja.
Hast du nicht hoch genug angesetzt, Stefan? Das ist das Problem, die geben einem nicht einfach nur so Geld, das ist der Haken an der Sache, sondern da muss man wirklich gegenfinanzieren, man muss, wenn man einen Antrag stellt, schon wissen, wo kommt das andere Geld her. Die geben ja maximal 50 Prozent. Also 50 Prozent von dem Geld, das man hat? Ich mache jetzt ein Spiel die nächsten zwei Jahre, das kostet mich irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 100.000 Euro. Dann muss ich mindestens 50.000 Euro irgendwo haben. Und zwar nicht so, die besorge ich dann, gib mir erstmal die Kohle, sondern die muss ich irgendwo haben, garantiert.
Wie habt ihr das gemacht? Wo habt ihr das Geld herbekommen?
Okay, also man muss es auch nicht unbedingt haben. Also es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die kann man machen. Also wir hatten es auch, also was wir gemacht haben, war eine Gehaltsrückstellung. Das machen die beim Film sehr häufig.
Gehabt haben werden.
Genau, sozusagen wir bezahlen uns unsere Gehälter nicht aus, solange bis wir und dieses theoretische Gehalt, was wir nicht ausbezahlt haben, bis es sich so angehäuft hat, dass das 50% hat.
Um bei dem Fall zu bleiben, ihr arbeitet solange, bis ihr 50.000 Euro verdient hättet.
Hättet, genau. Und dann schuldet uns die Firma, also mir und Riad als Angestellten, 50.000 Euro insgesamt. Und das haben wir sozusagen aufgeschrieben, dass wir das machen werden. Und dadurch hat es dann funktioniert. Unterm Strich hieß das natürlich, dass wir dann, solange wir uns kein Geld auszahlen konnten, von unserem Ersparten leben müssten. Also irgendwoher muss man immer Geld haben.
Oder jemanden, der einen durchfüttert.
Oder der einem hilft oder so. Oder Teilzeitjob oder was auch immer.
Jetzt, das will ich auch gleich noch fragen, ob es irgendwie so Brot- und Butterjobs für Spieleentwickler gibt, also klar, du kannst dann mal in der Kneipe arbeiten gehen oder irgendwas machen, was Ganze mit dem Job zu tun hat. Aber wie gesagt, kommen wir gleich zu. Erstmal noch die Frage, ihr habt das darin zurückgezahlt. Wenn ich jetzt nur die heutige Sendung rekapitle, bedeutet das, ihr habt genug getwittert. Und deswegen habt ihr euer Spiel gut verkauft. Oder wie ist das passiert?
Ja, tatsächlich haben wir Twitter sehr viel bedient. Wir haben genauso wie Stefan auch sehr aktiv über die Entwicklung berichtet. Wir haben auch viele YouTube-Videos gemacht. Über die Entwicklung und haben so ein bisschen Blick hinter die Kulissen gegeben. Und waren generell eigentlich sehr aktiv. Wir haben dieses Early Access Modell gefahren, was auf Steam ist. Sprich, wir haben unser Spiel angefangen zu verkaufen, obwohl es noch gar nicht fertig war. Und haben das ein Jahr lang gemacht.
Eine Beta-Version sozusagen.
Ja, genau. Und haben aber alle zwei Wochen eine neue Version veröffentlicht, die unseren Spielern zugänglich gemacht.
Jetzt ist ja das Internet nicht nur voller netter Leute. Fängt man sich dann nicht lauter Leute ein, die sagen, die kaufen mal ein nicht fertiges Spiel und sagen, das Spiel ist doch gar nicht fertig.
Ja, gibt's auf jeden Fall. Aber da hat eben, diese Flucht nach vorne war, glaube ich, ganz gut. Also wirklich das Zeigen, hey, guck mal, wir sind einfach nur Menschen, die dieses Spiel machen. Also, Ried und ich haben relativ früh angefangen, uns vor die Kamera zu stellen und einfach aus dem Nähkästchen zu plaudern, alle zwei Wochen immer zu den neuen Versionen. Und haben auch unsere Gesichter in die Kamera gehängt. Und haben das auch immer nicht so professionell gemacht, sondern so in einem Cut, ohne große Modifizierungen. Und ich glaube, dadurch wurde klar, hey, das sind einfach nur nette Leute, die versuchen, irgendwie das da zu reißen. Deswegen haben wir eigentlich relativ wenig diesen Hate abbekommen. Sondern die Leute haben einfach gesehen, okay, die strengen sich wirklich an, die sind dabei, die machen nicht dieses typische Early Access, wenn man da so ein bisschen drinsteckt, gibt's halt so das Klischee, die nehmen das Geld und dann hören die auf zu kommunizieren und machen die an dem Spiel weiter. Da haben wir auf jeden Fall gegen gearbeitet.
Ist es wichtig als Spieleentwickler, dass man da auch mit seiner Personality drin ist?
Ähm, nicht unbedingt. Also, das ist nicht kompatibel bei allen Menschen oder für alle Spiele. Ich fand's hilfreich. Also, es macht auf jeden Fall einen Bonus-Ding, glaube ich, wenn man das ausspielen kann, wenn man dafür gemacht ist. Kann es funktionieren, aber ist jetzt nicht eine Notwendigkeit.
Und das hat gereicht, dass sich dann genug Leute für das Spiel interessiert haben, dass es dann, als es auch gut war, gekauft wurde?
Genau, ich wollte auch noch mal sagen, es war auch, glaube ich, normal, hat auch spielerisch überzeugt.
Aber man braucht halt beides, ne? Du brauchst halt sowohl die Leute, also das muss gut sein, oder du brauchst ein richtig gutes Spiel, ne?
Also wir hatten ja nur so ein mittelmäßig gutes Spiel, aber konnten gut reden und haben es verkauft. Naja, und es wurde dann auch ein gutes Spiel, über den Zeitraum hinweg. Es sind verschiedene Konstellationen, die da funktionieren, aber in erster Linie ist es immer ganz praktisch, wenn man ein ziemlich gutes Spiel hat.
Okay, gut, klingt einleuchtend.
Willst du mich noch mal rausfragen, dass wir das Geld zurückbezahlt haben? Ansonsten würde ich noch mal gerne erzählen, dass wir so einen großen Scheck gemacht haben. Das war voll cool, wir haben so einen großen Scheck gemacht. Den hab ich von Hand gebaut. Dann wurden wir auf die Bühne gerufen und dann durften wir so einen großen Scheck übergeben. So ein Übersize, so ein Lifesize. Und es gibt das Gerücht, dass die Chefin vom Medienboard, die hat da in ihrem Büro die ganzen Wände zugekleistert mit so übergroßen Shacks. Und da hängt unsere jetzt auch angeblich.
Also jetzt Rückzahlungs-Shacks?
Der Rückzahlungs-Shack.
Von euch schon, aber an der Wand. Weil du hast ja gesagt, nur 20% zahlen zurück.
Nee, aber aus den Spielen. Aus dem innovativen audiovisuellen Inhalte, was zu keiner Kategorie von Spielen ist. Da sind es glaube ich nur 80%. Bei den anderen sind es noch weniger. Bei dem Film und so. Nein.
Aber ihr habt es geschafft. Ich wollte jetzt noch mal zurückkommen zu diesen Jobs. Wie ist es eigentlich zu sagen, wenn es gerade nicht klappt? Gibt es so Schwarzbrot-Jobs? Internetradio geht immer. Internetradio? Die Honorare hier, also die Honorare beim Chaosradio als Gast sind ja so hoch wie bei den Antifa-Demonstrationen.
Gut, das kann man ja wieder ein Jahr entwickeln.
Nein, aber ehrlich gesagt, gibt es so Dinge, die man nebenbei macht, also die ihr macht oder wo ihr Saftladen-Kollegen und Kolleginnen beobachtet, wo man häufiger mal sieht, okay, das sind anscheinend so Dinge, die kann man als Spieleentwickler sehr gut nebenbei machen?
Also ja, ja, sehr gut, ist schwierig, glaube ich. Also bei mir ist es einfach, ich doziere nebenbei und das habe ich das letzte Jahr über, als ich eben noch kein Geld hatte vom Medienbord, relativ viel gemacht. Das hat die Miete bezahlt. Und Grafiker haben relativ häufig so Freelance-Jobs entweder bei Spielen oder jetzt seit einiger Zeit gibt es ja viele Filmfirmen, die auch noch so VR-Kram produzieren. Oder so Effektfirmen gibt es ja einige in Berlin. Und die dann ganz froh sind über Leute, die sich mit sowas auskennen. Das sind so Brot-Jobs.
Das ist natürlich schwierig. Also Auftragsarbeiten muss man aber auch aufpassen, weil die dann oft teilweise, muss man Geld hinterherrennen, typische Freelancer-Problematik. Und man verwendet dann seine Zeit darauf, diese Auftragsarbeiten zu machen. Und wann macht man dann das Spiel?
Das wollte ich gerade fragen. Man hört ja immer das Klischee von Leuten, die aus so großen Firmen wie ihr bei Jager kommen. Man geht da auch weg, weil es da die sogenannte Crunchtime gibt, die dann immer ist. Also dieses, man arbeitet viel, viel mehr als man eigentlich sollte. Arbeitet man dann im Saftladen weniger?
Also ich habe noch nie so wenig gearbeitet in meinem Leben wie jetzt.
Das ist eine gute Sache.
So viel Urlaub gehabt und so viel verdient.
Wie sind die anderen beiden auf dem Sofa?
Äh, nee, das kann ich von mir nicht behaupten. Aber ich meine, mein Spiel ist ja auch noch nicht draußen. Das ist dann nach, wird das dann alles super? Nee, ja, ich hoff's aber. Also es ist schon so bei mir, dass mein Ziel nicht ist, irgendwie die 60 Stunden Wochen zu ruppen. Das macht keinen Sinn und halte ich nicht für erstrebenswert. Und dann würd ich's glaub ich auch nicht machen.
Ich freu mich auf Stefan Edwards.
Aber ja, also ich muss im Moment eher mehr arbeiten, würd ich sagen, als Angestellter. Aber ich glaub ich auch normal in so ner Grundungsphase.
Stefan?
Ja, also ich hab ja auch noch nichts, was sich verkauft. Also geh ich natürlich jetzt ganz stark dann in Vorleistung. Das hat sich auch nicht verändert, glaube ich, seit der Zeit vor dem Saftladen und im Saftladen jetzt. Sag mal ein bisschen Ortswechsel. Ich mach schon sehr viele Stunden.
Also ich bin halt so 6, 7 Tage dann immer dran.
Und von morgens bis abends. Das ist schon viel.
Stefan ist volles Tier.
Aber das ist okay. Ich glaube, mit meiner Frau habe ich mich ganz gut arrangiert.
Und wir haben halt keine Kinder. Und dann lässt sich das für den Moment, glaube ich, ganz gut machen. Ist das auch, das ist eine total doofe Frage, weil die Antwort so offen sich ist. Aber ist es auch ein Vorteil, dieses im kleinen Team und in so einem Saftladen-Kollektiv zu arbeiten, dass man dann, also vielleicht nicht weniger arbeitet, aber freier daran ist, sich das einzuteilen?
Absolut.
Oder arbeitet man dann so viel, dass es eh egal ist?
Und also unbedingt, ich finde das, ich genieße das so dermaßen im Vergleich zum Angestellten da sein, dass ich mir die Zeit selber einteilen kann.
Dass man einfach arbeitet, so wie es Sinn macht einfach.
Und dass ich sagen kann, ja genau, es kommt halt mal vor, kommt durchaus mal vor, dass ich irgendwie, okay es ist jetzt ein Sonntag, aber die Frau mit dem Kind ist weg. Und ich habe meine Ruhe und ich bin zu Hause und ich habe voll, ich merke so, okay, jetzt habe ich eine geile Idee und jetzt setze ich mich hin und dann schreibe ich irgendwie den ganzen Tag Kram oder arbeite was am Spiel. Und dann nehme ich mir aber halt den Montag oder irgendwie einen Tag frei, weil ich merke so, hey, Papa hat keinen Bock und das läuft nicht und so. Und das ist, das ist fantastisch.
Oder man setzt sich auch noch mal abends hin. Oder man geht zum Beispiel früher nach Hause, um noch mal den Nachmittagabend mit seiner Familie zu verbringen. Und wenn dann alle im Bett sind, dann kann man sich noch mal abends hinsetzen zwischen acht und elf oder so und auch noch mal was reisen. Also man einfach dieses Flexible selber bestimmen, wie und wann und wo ich arbeite. Das ist super befreiend.
Jetzt haben wir, das ist so geil, ich habe mir am Anfang Sorge gemacht, dass wir irgendwie zwei Stunden nicht voll kriegen. Jetzt haben wir einen Themenblock noch gar nicht angeschnitten. Also der taucht aber so ein bisschen durch. Also Spiele machen ist mehr als nur Spiele machen. Also zum Beispiel kann man als Dozent anscheinend auch arbeiten. Es gibt diese Talk-and-Play-Reihe. Ihr macht im Saftladen dieses, dass man sich regelmäßig trifft und auch mal spricht und redet. Es entstehen zusammen Dinge. Aber bei Maschinen meint, ihr hattet in den letzten, ich weiß nicht, Jahren, letztes Jahr oder zwei Jahren mit dem Goethe-Institut zusammengearbeitet. Was genau war das? Und ist das so ein einmaliges Ding gewesen? Oder ist das auch Spiele machen?
Okay, das sind jetzt verschiedene Fragen. Also kurz erklärend, mit dem Goethe-Institut haben wir zusammengearbeitet für 15 Monate lang. Haben wir eine Kooperation gemacht. Und zwar sind wir gemeinsam mit dem Goethe-Institut in acht unterschiedliche Länder der Welt gereist. Zum Beispiel waren wir in Mexiko City, wir waren in Südkorea, wir waren in Boston, wir waren in Novosibirsk, Russland, Sao Paulo. Und haben dort vor Ort mit Menschen, nicht nur Entwicklern, sondern einfach nur Menschen, ein Game Jam organisiert. Ein Game Jam ist ganz kurz, meistens im begrenzten Zeitrahmen abgesteckt. Es kommen fremde Menschen zusammen. Und die entwickeln innerhalb von einem sehr kurzen Zeitraum ein Spiel, was man spielen kann. Was fertig ist sozusagen, was man rausgeben kann in die Welt und was eigentlich von Leuten einfach konsumiert werden kann. Das haben wir da gemacht. Die Spiele hatten alle das Thema, dass die Menschen vor Ort versuchen sollten, ihre politischen Realität da einfließen zu lassen oder irgendwelche Ideen oder Ansätze, die für sie politisch schienen, in diese Spiele reinzubringen. Also sprich, es waren nicht unbedingt Serious Games im Sinne von, die waren total langweilig und dröge. Es waren auch schon lustige und unterhaltsame Spiele, aber die hatten alle irgendwo eine Komponente, die mehr war als nur, haha, ist lustig zum Spielen. Genau, das haben wir zusammen mit dem Goethe-Institut gemacht. Das Goethe-Institut hat zusammen mit dem Auswärtigen Amt sozusagen die Finanzierung gestemmt und hat die Logistik gemacht, hat vor Ort die Locations ausgewählt und uns mit der Einladung der Partizipierten geholfen. Und Maschinenmensch hat das Know-how reingebracht, was Spiele machen anging und auch die Organisation Game Jam. Wie läuft das ab? Was gibt es da für Sachen, die man zu beachten muss? Und auch währenddessen das Mentoring der Leute, um ihnen zu helfen, diese Spiele zu bauen. Genau, das haben wir so gemacht. Und das war auch Spiele machen, ja.
Aber dahinter steckt da so dieses, ich mache also nicht mein eigenes Spiel, sondern ich benutze die Werkzeuge, die ich durchs Spiele machen gelernt habe, um damit was zu transportieren. Also in dem Fall, um politischem Erleben Ausdruck zu verdienen. Man kann sich auch vorstellen, dass man das in der Pädagogik nutzt und sagt, ich mache Spiele machen mit Menschen zusammen. Man kann sich auch überlegen, vielleicht kann man auch Selbsterfahrungsgruppen gründen, die beim Spiele machen Dinge aufarbeiten. Ist das für euch, blutet das sozusagen ins Leben aus? Und vielleicht auch ins Berufsleben? Und man kann damit mehr machen als nur Spiele machen? Oder ist das eher die Ausnahme, weil sowas immer so aufwendig ist, dass es dann auch finanziert werden muss?
Nö, kann man auf jeden Fall nutzen. Also Spiele homogenisieren ja total gut. Weil die Leute, die sich damit befassen und die das cool finden, die haben auf jeden Fall so einen Common Base. Einerseits sprechen die oft Englisch. Dann haben die alle wahrscheinlich so die Geschichten, wie wir uns jetzt am Anfang vorgestellt haben. So in meiner Kindheit habe ich das und das gemacht und so. Da hat man automatisch schon Themen, über die man sprechen kann. Und das ist dann so ein bisschen dieses Game Jam spezifische. Das ist eine sehr persönliche, intime Erfahrung, die man dadurch lebt. Weil im Falle von der Art Games Reihe, was wir mit dem Goethe-Institut gemacht haben, waren das 48 Stunden hatten die Zeit. Und die haben diese Zeit sehr effektiv nutzen wollen. Da baut sich sofort ein sehr starkes Engagement auf. Die haben auch wenig geschlafen. Die haben dann sozusagen gecruncht währenddessen, um das Bestmögliche zu erreichen. Und das zusammen mit Fremden. Da haben sich dann Gruppen getroffen, zusammengefunden vor Ort. Es war so im Schnitt so zwischen 50 und 80 Partizipienten, teilweise sogar über 120 Leute. Und die finden sich dann so im Schnitt meistens in Fünfergruppen zusammen. Und oft kennen die sich gar nicht vorher. Und die müssen sich alle einigen, die müssen Kompromisse eingehen, um ein Spiel zu verfolgen. Die müssen alle am gleichen Strang ziehen. Teilweise stehen die unter großem Stress, weil jeder will das Beste für das Spiel haben. Teilweise stehen die unter Schlafentzug auch ein bisschen, sind müde, erschöpft am zweiten, dritten Tag. Also da wird es sehr schnell sehr intim und eng.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei dem war, aber bei Game Jams lese ich ab und zu, ihr könnt vorbeikommen, auch wenn ihr gar keine Ahnung vom Coden und Spielemacher habt, ist das wirklich so?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Jeder kann da irgendwie was beitragen. Also selbst wenn ich überhaupt nichts kann, kann ich immer noch das Spiel spielen, ich kann den Leuten helfen, indem ich irgendwas organisiere, gucke, dass ich die Kommunikation unter den Menschen verbessere. Da findet jeder, kann ja irgendwas. Und da findet jeder auch seine Rolle, wenn man da hingeht. Also ich glaube, es wird leider viel zu wenig genutzt. Also die Leute haben immer so Hemmungen, dann hinzugeben.
Aber jeder, der da mitmacht, der würde sich freuen über einfach andere Leute, die wieder andere Ideen mit einbringen. Weil wir dann wirklich bald zu Ende sind, würde ich jetzt gerne noch ein paar Sachen einsammeln, falls man jetzt in die Sendung gehört, dann sehr schnell so, man, das klingt ja ganz cool, ich würde da vielleicht noch ein bisschen näher rein stoppern. Also was man jetzt machen kann, was schon gesagt wurde, ich kann tatsächlich nicht trauen, zu einem Game Jam zu gehen. Habt ihr jetzt bestätigt zumindest. Es gibt diese Talk and Play Reihe, die ist wann? Alle?
Alle zwei Monate.
Alle zwei Monate auf berlingamescene.com gehen. Da gibt es einen Kalender, unter anderem auch ein Reiter extra für das Talk and Play, berlingamescene.com.
Es gibt einmal im Jahr die Amaze, die ist immer im späten April. Im April, also wenn Berlin Games Week ist.
BerlinMinigameJam auch.
Was ist das?
Das ist einmal im Monat ein 8-Stunden-Gamejam, der stattfindet. Der ist im Koop, beim Komposator. Ich glaube, die URL ist BerlinGameJam.de oder BerlinMinigameJam.de.
Ist aber auch auf BerlinGameScene.
Ja, genau.
Findet man auch.
Und wenn ich jetzt so ein bisschen konkreter, wenn ich denke, ich will mich mit Spielentwicklung beschäftigen, was ist die erste Stelle, wo der sagt, oder meinetwegen auch nur der Google-Suchbegriff, den ich eingeben muss, oder Suchmaschine eurer Wahl, womit fange ich an? Du hast es vorhin schon gesagt, Unity kann man anfangen. Wird es mit dem Kopf schwer, so, ist das das richtige?
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Also Unity finde ich schon ganz schön oben eingestiegen. Also ich würde eher wahrscheinlich mit Smodding reingehen. Also überhaupt erst mal anfangen sozusagen, weil manchmal ist ja...
Also ist es wichtiger, etwas zu machen, wo ich schnell was sehen kann, als mir was Komplexes rauszusuchen, was ich erst mal lerne?
Das kommt auf dich persönlich an.
Okay, aber es gibt diese beiden Wege sozusagen.
Ich würde zumindest sagen, Unity nenne ich einfach mal, weil es so viel Material dazu gibt, weil es auch so viele qualitative YouTube-Videos dafür gibt.
Also könnte man sagen, wenn ich vielleicht von Programmieren eh schon Ahnung habe, dann kann ich damit vielleicht gut einsteigen. Wenn ich sozusagen eher, wie ihr euch so ein bisschen vorhin angefällt, ja, also Coden, hm, nun kann ich ja nicht so. Dann kann ich sozusagen eher mir ein bestehendes Spiel suchen, was Modding kommt. Also es gibt ja Spiele, die Level-Editoren mitbringen.
Zum Beispiel, oder es gibt ganze Spiele, wo es mit nichts anderes geht. Minecraft, Kreativmodus. Mario Maker, sowas. Und einfach, also ich denke, es ist gar nicht so anders als hacken. Was ist einfach, man muss von dem passiven, ich konsumiere, was mir vorgesetzt wird, wechseln auf die Seite, wo man sagt, okay, jetzt mach ich selber mal was. Und was auch, ja, also ein Zugang wäre, also Unity ist sicher ein Tool, es ist eine Game Engine und das ist sicher ein Tool, das wahnsinnig gut dokumentiert ist. Und das ist halt erstmal kostenlos, aber es ist nicht, also es hat schon auch trotzdem eine große Einstiegshürde, würde ich sagen, weil man relativ schnell zumindest einigermaßen programmieren können sollte oder es lernen muss.
Was ist, was sind bei der Spielentwicklung der für euch der häufigste Frustrationspunkt oder Dinge, die euch frustrieren und wie überwindet ihr die? Spielentwicklung ist so toll, es gibt nie Frustrationspunkte.
Es dauert immer alles so lange. Es dauert alles immer länger. Du hast die coole Idee, du kannst es umsetzen. Es läuft nicht mal schlecht, aber es dauert einfach länger. Und dann ist einfach keine Zeit mehr da. Das ist eigentlich das Problem.
Meistens, wenn es richtig losgeht, dann muss man eigentlich fertig sein.
Genau, das ist tatsächlich frustrierend, wenn man Dinge, die man gerne noch gemacht hätte, nicht tun kann, weil die Zeit weg ist.
Ich habe jetzt noch zum Schluss die Gretchenfrage. Wenn man euch so zuhört, dann habe ich den Eindruck gewonnen, wenn ich wirklich selber Spiele machen will, im Sinne von, ich möchte auch in einer handwerklichen, selbst erfahrenen Art ein Spiel auf die Welt bringen, dann muss ich das so machen wie ihr, also in einem kleinen Team mindestens. Und darf auf gar keinen Fall eine große Firma geben, weil da ist es eher ein Job. Ist das so oder ist das nur so ein Eindruck, den ich jetzt habe und eigentlich ist das alles ganz anders?
Also das kommt ein bisschen auf die Firma und das Projekt an, ich denke, und vielleicht auch manchmal auf den Zeitraum. Also ich habe schon auch, ich habe ja das Beispiel bei Jäger, hatte ich schon das Gefühl, dass ich ans Back of the Line auch handwerklich mitgearbeitet habe und auch was zu dem Spiel beigetragen habe, obwohl das am Ende 120 Leute waren. Aber und gleichzeitig ist eben der große Vorteil, den der große Studio hat und gerade am Anfang hat, muss man auch ganz klar sagen, ist, dass man erstens bezahlt wird und zweitens, ja wirklich, und zweitens Dinge lernt. Dass da ganz viele andere Leute sind, die total gut sind, die viel besser sind als man selber und von denen man lernen kann. Und das würde ich nicht von der Hand weisen, aber für mich persönlich ist jetzt dieses im kleinen Team arbeiten sehr erfüllend.
Du hast halt auch schon viel Erfahrung mitgebracht, ne? Ich sehe immer wieder junge Leute, die dann sozusagen direkt ohne den Einstieg in eine Spielfirma unabhängig werden und die rennen halt teilweise in so offensichtliche Wände rein, wo man so im Nachhinein denkt zum Menschen. Ja, für uns offensichtlich. Weil wir halt einfach schon Erfahrung gesammelt haben. Deswegen, ich weiß auch nie genau, was ich den Leuten raten soll. Zuerst in ein großes Studio oder ein mittelgroßes Studio, geht bloß nicht in so ein riesengroßes Studio am Anfang. Also bei Ubisoft oder so was würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt, weiß nicht genau. Vielleicht ist da auch cool, da kann man sich super spezialisieren. Aber ich weiß nicht, was ich raten würde. Weil manchmal verliert man auch so ein bisschen die Edge, also dieses Anarchistische, was so junge Leute manchmal haben und dann so Spiele wie Hotline Miami entstehen oder so was. Das geht auch verloren, wenn man zu lange auf einem gemütlichen Stuhl sitzt.
Ich hätte mir jetzt so eine schwarz-weiße Antwort gewünscht. Ihr müsstet ja wieder differenzieren. Weil jetzt die Zeit wirklich rum ist, werde ich nicht mehr fragen, was eure einzelnen nächsten Projekte oder möglicherweise Deadlines sind, sondern es gab neulich, hattet ihr so eine offene Veranstaltung, da konnte man von euch allen und auch von den anderen mal mit Saftladen sehen, an was ihr gerade arbeitet und das sogar ausprobieren. Wann ist die nächste dieser Art?
Bestimmt zur nächsten großen Veranstaltung in Berlin. Versuchen wir jetzt eigentlich immer das zu machen, also mindestens zu Amaze oder zu Gamesweek, die jetzt aber schon dieses Jahr war. Ansonsten würde mir jetzt spontan keins einfallen.
Aber wir haben die Website saftladen.berlin und da gibt es auch ein Newsletter.
Genau, abonniert den Newsletter.
Alles klar, sehr schön. Dann vielen Dank, der Servat, Jörg Friedrich, Stefan Höfelbrink und Johannes Christmann.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Alle vom Saftladen. Vielen Dank, liebes Publikum, dass ihr doch noch in die erste Reihe gekommen seid. Ja, das war's für heute. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter und ich habe noch eine kleine Nachricht für euch. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.